voilà mes chers collègues je vous
propose de commencer notre réunion de
commission même si je sais qu'un certain
nombre de nos collègues quelque peu
retardatair ce matin nous sommes à la
fin de l'année donc voilà les travaux
parlementa s'arrête ce soir donc il y a
déjà un petit peu un petit air de repos
qui flotte dans l'atmosphère du Sénat
qui vont nous rejoindre en tout cas je
suis très heureuse bien évidemment que
vous puissiez participer à cette table
ronde que nous vous avions annoncé et
que nous avons voulu organiser sur
l'économie pastorale et l'avenir du
pastoralisme alors bien sûr le sujet qui
tient à cœur un certain nombre d'entre
nous sur la prédation et le loup fera
partie des débats mais voilà c'est le le
le chapeau est beaucoup plus large c'est
l'économie pastorale et l'avenir du
pastoralisme et en tout premier lieu
avant de commencer nos débats je veux
juste souhaiter un très joyeux
anniversaire à notre collègue Amel gaker
voilà donc nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir ce matin quatre invités aux
approches complémenta pour traiter d'une
réalité elle-même plurielle cardinale
pour le dynamisme de nombreux
territoires je veux parler de l'économie
pastorale l'objet de cette table ronde
vous l'aurez compris est de ne pas
réduire le pastoralisme à son seul face-
à-face avec le loup comme on le fait
trop souvent mais d'insister sur sa
dimension économique et plus
généralement sur les aménités du
pastoralisme ou plutôt des pastoralisme
pour nos territoires le pastoralisme
constitue une chance pour les Alpes pour
les Pyrénées pour le Massif Central et
pour tout l'arc méditerranéen mais il
souffre de handicap structurel souvent
lié d'ailleurs à ces mêmes territoires
d'un côté c'est la transumence tout
juste reconnu au patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité de l'UNESCO
avec le potentiel touristique qui va
avec la production de viande de fromage
AOP qu'on nous envie dans le monde
entier le stock de carbone par le
maintien de prairies ou encore la
prévention du risque de feu de forêt
la sauvegarde de la biodiversité et
l'entretien des paysages par l'ouverture
des milieux de l'autre force est de
constater la très faible rentabilité
économique liée au handicap naturel la
décapitalisation qui n'a pas attendu les
grands carnivores pour se manifester et
bien sûr je le disais la prédation
surtout celle du loup dans le quart
sud-est du pays mais aussi celle de
l'ours dans les Pyrénées dont un récent
rapport nous dit que la population
atteindrait 350 individus à l'horizon
2050 suscitant la protestation de la
fédération nationale
ovin ici
représenté s'agissant du loup après une
relative stabilité entre 2019 et
2021 l'année 2022 a marqué un tournant
avec près de 20 % de hausse de victimes
essentiellement
auovin sur les 9 premiers mois de
l'année
2023 dans le seul département des Alpes
Maritimes on relève près de 600 constats
d'attaques indemnisables ou en cours
d'instruction pour plus de 1500 bêtes
victimes au total plus de 50 département
sont aujourd'hui concernés par la
prédation dont certains où les mesures
de protection
ne sont pas dans les habitudes le
gouvernement a présenté au groupe
national lou dont je suis membre un
projet de plan national d'action loup et
activité d'élevage
2024-2029 mise à la consultation depuis
dans ce contexte 15000 contributions ont
été adressées en juillet les
représentant de l'élevage avaient quitté
la table des négociations à cause de la
sous estimation du nombre de loups qui
est finalement passé cet été en l'espace
de 2 mois de 906 à 1104 loups
répertoriés et
comptabilisés depuis septembre ce sont
les associations de protection de la
nature qui sont sorti des négociations
madamees messieurs pourrez-vous nous
présenter brièvement les principales
évolutions contenues dans ce plan ainsi
que ses sous-jacents politiques violence
psychologique pour les éleveurs la
prédation suscite aussi l'émotion parce
qu'elle compromet un équilibre
économiquement fragile qui permet une
valorisation exceptionnelle des produits
agricoles une ZDP ou zone difficilement
protégeable assouplissant les protocoles
de tir a été mise en place dans la
région de production du Rockfort l'avyon
le Tarne la lozer et l'éau où sont
concentrés 1 million de brebis ce qui
représente un enjeu économique
considérable est-ce réplicable ailleurs
à quelles conditions d'autres ADP
pourrait-elle être mise en place plus
largement des conflits d'usage existent
ou se font jour entre pastoralisme
civile culture et tourisme on connaît la
réserve traditionnelle des forestiers
sur le pastoralisme craignant la
pression du paturage sur la végétation
arbustive on on observe également de
plus en plus de difficultés pour les
randonneurs les vtétistes en lien avec
les 7000 chiens de protection des
troupeaux financés dans le cadre du Plan
loup quels sont les verrous à lever pour
renforcer la complémentarité de ces
activités et prévenir au maximum les
conflits d'usage dont ce sont bien
souvent et très souvent les mares qui
doivent aussi être amenés à les résoudre
des évolutions législatives ou
réglementairire vous paraissent-elles
souhaitabl
envisageable au-delà de la prédation et
des conflits d'usage je demanderai enfin
à nos invités de nous donner des pistes
pour améliorer la visibilité des
activités pastorales dont l'équation
financière repose en général sur une
proportion d'aide publique importante
peut-ons par exemple imaginer mieux
rémunérer les aménités positives du
pastoralis
en optimisant des cobénéfices mutuels
avec le tourisme ou la syviculture voir
par la mise en place de paiement pour
services
environnementaux pour répondre à ces
très vastes question dont je ne doute
pas qu'elles seront complétées par
l'ensemble des commissaires présents à
cette audition je souhaite donc la
bienvenue à Madame Brigitte singl
secrétaire générale de la fédération
nationale
ovine et éleveuse dans l'héros à
Monsieur Jean-Paul cell préfet référent
pour la mise en œuvre du plan national
d'action loup et activité d'élevage que
nous avions déjà eu le plaisir de
recevoir au sein d'un groupe de travail
sur la prédation et sur le loup propre
aur que je préside et qui opère sous la
coordination de la préfette de région
Auvergne ronalpe Madame Fabienne buciot
Monsieur François Balic maire du Vernet
représentant la Fédération nationale des
communes pastorales que je connais plus
particulièrement puisque cette
fédération nationale des communes
pastorales est présidée par une maire de
mon département Denise lebof que je
salue à distance et Monsieur Charles Dex
ingénieur forestier honoraire président
de l'association forêt méditerranéenne
et spécialiste du silvo pastoralisme
voilà je vous cède la parole dans cet
ordre on va commencer par vous madame
ensuite Monsieur le Préfet monsieur
Balic et Monsieur DX conclura cette
entrée en matière si j'ose dire et
ensuite je céderai la parole en priorité
à nos collègues savoyarde et au
savoyarde sylvien Noël et Martine Berté
je pensais que notre collègue Cyril
pelva que j'avais invité également qui
fait partie de la commission aménagement
du territoire et développement durable
serait là s'il venait être là on lui
céderait la parole en priorité bien sûr
et après on ouvrira le flot des
questions à l'ensemble des commissaires
madame la secrétaire générale je vous
laisse la
parole voilà merci madameon bonjour à
tous effectivement je me présente je
suis Brigitte singl je suis éleveuse de
breettière dans le département de
l'éau nous fabriquons du lait pour la
transformation en Rockfort voilà donc on
est comme vous l'avez dit en zone
difficilement protégeable pour le loup
mais je pense que le sujet ici dépasse
vous l'avez très bien dit la thématique
de la prédation il s'agit aujourd'hui de
voir comment on peut sauver le le
pastoralisme et en tout cas de
d'identifier les les difficultés que
qu'il peut rencontrer ce qui peut
paraître paradoxal quand on voit que
c'est une pratique qui colle
complètement avec les attentes
sociétales et qui est en phase avec ce
qu'on attend sur le plan environnemental
puisque un des des enjeux majeurs
évidemment du pastoralisme c'est les les
aménités qu'il ramènent à travers
l'entretien des pays visage l'entretien
des territoires qui qui génère quand
même beaucoup de de facilités pour le
tourisme que ce soit du tourisme blanc
ou du tourisme vert on voit également
que l'ouverture des milieux est
extrêmement favorable au maintien de la
biodiversersité et ce cette activité
ancestrale d'élevage extensifin se
caractérise par le fait qu'effectivement
on est très en lien entre le berger
l'animal et et l'environnement dans
lequel on vie voilà donc ça c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est particulier
et et aujourd'hui on se rend compte
aussi que euh à travers tout ça on on
rencontre des difficultés hein mais bon
je vais d'abord dresser le je dirais
l'activité économique que représente le
pastoralisme parce que bien souvent on
nous cantonne dans tout ce qui est
environnemental et entretien de l'espace
mais en tant qu'éleveuse je voudrais
quand même insister sur le fait que
notre métier c'est de produire et
qu'effectivement à travers le
pastoralisme on produit et on produit
des des produits d' de qualité puisquil
il y a énormément vous l'avez très bien
dit d'AOP fromageère mais il y a
également des labels en viande donc
derrière il y a une activité économique
qui contribue au dynamisme économique
des territoires parce qu'on voit que sur
ces territoires ruraux dans certains
coins et ben l'élevage est quasiment la
seule activité économique alors le
tourisme on le voit le tourisme blanc on
le voit surtout dans l'arc alpin et et
pyrénéen mais le pastoralisme ça veut
pas dire que transumance et que il y a
du pastoralisme qui peut-être sédentaire
ou collectif il y a ou Transhumain
pardon et il y a également du
pastoralisme qui est individuel ou
collectif donc on rencontre les deux et
l'arc méditerranéen justement et
présente bien ces différences-l parce
que nous avons sur l'AR méditerranéen
des exploitations pastorales qui sont
individuel et sédentaire qui ne
transhument pas on en a d'autres qui
transhument c'est particulièrement vrai
dans les plaines du balanged donc voilà
donc ces différences là il faut qu'on
voit que ça apporte quand même de la
vitalité sur les territoire de
l'économie ça ramène de l'économie et et
au-delà de ça en plus on se dit bon nous
éleveur comment on on évolue là-dedans
parce que je vous ai parlé d'une
activité ancestrale mais évidemment que
les bergers vivent avec leur temps et
que on se doit aussi d'être dans la
modernité et on se doit aussi d'être
évidemment dans le dans l'innovation
parce qu'on peut pas rester comme on
était au siècle dernier souvent je dis
on a une vision quand on connaît pas le
pastoralisme une vision très bucolique
de la chose l'image d'Épinal on voit le
berger on voit voilà mais aujourd'hui
les choses évoluent et nos jeunes aussi
ben ils veulent ils veulent autre chose
et et notamment l'attractivité du métier
reste quelque chose qui nous fait
énormément qui nous préoccupe parce que
il va falloir renouveler les générations
qui a la transmission d'un savoir-faire
ce savoir-faire il est pas évident on
l'enseigne pas forcément donc il faut
voir aussi comment on peut transmettre
le savoir et ça c'est c'est important
pour faire perdurer l'activité donc euh
tout ça bon euh euh ça ça montre les
enjeux que l'on a et il faut pas
s'imaginer que le pastoralisme est à
part des enjeux de l'élevage en général
euh voilà le renouvellement des
génération c'est vraiment quelque chose
de d'hyper important par rapport à ça
donc euh ça ça représente un frein
aujourd'hui parce que pour que cette
activité perdure et ben on a besoin de
continuer à trouver des bergers et des
éleveurs qui veuillent bien
pratiquer ce métier qui demande quand
même beaucoup de d'astreintte de travail
et et et de contraintte et qui ne peut
se faire qu'avec passion ça c'est c'est
clair après euh je dirais que dans les
dans les freins que l'on peut rencontrer
aussi euh il y a le la préoccupation
constante que l'on a par rapport à
l'évolution des politiques publiques euh
euh les les éleveurs pastoraux sont des
éleveurs comme les autres ils ont besoin
aussi du soutien de la pâac je dirais
même plus peut-être plus encore donc on
voit que on a de plus en plus des soucis
pour arriver à faire reconnaître nos
surfaces pastorales dans le carcan de la
PAC je dirais en terme
d'éligibilité chaque fois qu'il y a des
réformes de la PAC on se rend compte à
quel point euh on est toujours obligé de
se justifier on nous rajoute des
contraintes on on on nous rajoute des
des découpages je dirais territoriaux en
faisant des zones de densité homogène
quand on connaît l'hétérogénéité des
territoires pastoraux on se dit c'est
quand même un problème on voit qu'il y a
un décalage là entre la réforme qui
s'écrit avec le stylo et et la réalité
sur les territoires donc ça c'est quand
même
préoccupant on a été obligé enfin je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques mais on a été obligé de
rentrer dans des systèmes dit de
rétropolation des surfaces et de
proratisation euh aujourd'hui
dans la nouvelle réforme de la PAC on
nous met un autre taux de chargement sur
ces surfaces là en
écartant en tout cas en ciblant en
rétropolation les surfaces ligneuses on
est toujoursé obligé de se justifier sur
la qualité de la ressource et souvent on
ne raisonne qu'à travers des ressources
ditit terbagère alors que nous la la
spécificité du pastoralisme c'est que on
va sur des prairies naturelles mais on
va également sur des surfaces qui sont
considérés qui sont constitués
d'arbustes qui sont constitués aussi de
ligneux et que les troupeaux se
nourrissent aussi de ressources
arbustives et fruitières et ça on a
beaucoup de mal à le quantifier on a
beaucoup de mal à à le faire comprendre
d'où l'idée de se dire que on va pas
redistribuer des aides pqu au surface
avec des surfaces qui n'auraient pas un
intérêt agricole mais encore faut-il
comprendre ce qu'est l'intérêt agrico
des surfaces et c'est quand on voit et
qu'on connaît l'interaction entre
l'éleveur l'animal et le territoire
qu'on peut comprendre ce qu'est une
ressource pastorale et ça bon ça ça nous
préoccupe quand même au plus haut point
parce que bon on vient d'entamer une
nouvelle réforme mais je sais pas en
2027 ce que ça va donner voilà donc ça
c'est c'est un point de vigilance qui
est très très important pour nous et
puis évidemment je peux pas terminer
sans parler de de la prédation puisque
la prédation pour nous c'est c'est un
problème incontournable on sait que ça
met dans le désarroi
bon nombre de d'éleveurs et que bon il y
a des plans de de protection des
troupeaux qui sont mis en place mais bon
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
euh c'est pas c'est pas satisfaisant
dans la mesure où ça limite peut-être un
peu les dégâts et encore quand on voit
le nombre de brebis prédaté on se pose
des questions sur l'efficacité de la
protection mais au-delà de ça on se dit
euh comment faire comprendre à des
éleveur quand on est dans l'urgence
d'une situation et qu'il faut des
réactivités immédiates qu'il faut passer
par un gcan administratif pas possible
euh on narrive pas à l'expliquer et
quelque chose qu'on arrive absolument
pas à quantifier c'est le stress que ça
représente pour les éleveurs c'est
l'impact psychologique que ça a sur les
familles parce que c'est quand même
dramatique et puis je je viens de vous
décrire ce vraiment le le le rôle très
proche qu'à l'éleveur avec les bêtes et
avec le territoire hein ça ça exprime
bien le fait que c'est une souffrance
terrible quand on retrouve ses bêtes
éventré égorgé on narrive pas à faire
supporter ça à des éleveurs donc voilà
la prédation est une menace c'est pas la
seule mais elle pèse énormément et
notamment sur le renouvellement des
générations parce que des fils
d'éleveurs qui sont passionnés et qui
voient leur père aujourd'hui dans des
difficultés énormes à cause de ça ils se
disent ben moi j'ai pas envie de vivre
ça donc ça va peser énormément et et ça
ça nous inquiète on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir je suppose j'espère que j'ai pas
été trop longue pas du tout madame la la
secrétaire générale merci déjà de ces
propos liminires je passe la parole au
préfet cell qui est référent pour la
mise en place du plan national d'action
Lou et activité d'élevage Monsieur le
Préfet c'est à vous merci madame la
Présidente donc je vais essayer d'être
là
aussi pardon le plus concis possible
pour laisser la place au dialogue je
crois que c'est c'est ça le plus
important je vais vous présenter les
axes les grands axes du nouveau PNA mais
avant je je juste un petit bilan de
l'année 2023 parce que aujourd'hui on
est dans la capacité
de de dresser un bilan provisoire certes
mais qui commence à être consolidé
alors nous sommes dans une année où la
prédation en terme d'attaque est
quasiment
stable par rapport à
2022 mais en terme de victimes
même si le terme est toujours un peu
baroque en terme de victime nous en
sommes sans doute à moins 9 % de
prédation
euh ceci s'accompagnant d'une campagne
de tir qui n'a pas eu
d'équivalent puisque nous à cette date
nous aurons tué 200
loups euh pour
169 l'année
dernière ce qui déjà était un un
record et la les moyens de
protection se sont accrus de 13% au
cours de
l'année avec une augmentation
du des financement de 6
millions cet accroissement est
sur les TR dernières années en moyenne
l'accroissement des moyens de protection
c'est plus
8% voilà les les grands chiffres de
l'année 2023 on pourra y revenir si vous
avez des questions particulières sur ce
sujet et notamment la comparaison avec
2022 et puis avec les autres années en
sachant que nous sommes si on excepte
l'année 2022 depuis 4 ans nous sommes
sur une une baisse constante du nombre
de
victimes et avec un ratio qui est le
ratio attaque victimes PL victime nombre
de victimes par attaque qui ne cesse de
diminuer puis actuellement il est en
moyenne de 3 il était beaucoup plus
élevé les années
précédentes le nouveau PNA qu'est-ce
qu'il apporte
euh il est nettement
je dirais pas en rupture mais il est
nettement différent des précédents
PNA et en quoi
est-il différent des précédents
PNA je vais vous donner les quatre
axes premier
axe c'est connaissance et conservation
de
l'espèce et pour la première fois je
détaillerai tout à l'heure pour la
première fois va être posée la question
d'une modification du statut de l'espèce
à l'intérieur d'un
PNA ainsi que des méthodes de comptage
deuxème axe c'est sur les moyens de
protection et le protocole de tir cela
nous a conduit à modifier l'arrêté
interministériel définissant les
conditions de
tir là aussi je j'en dirais un B 3è axe
je pense que ça rejoint pleinement le
thème de ce matin 3e
AX le ministre de l'Agriculture a
souhaité
et juste titre que soit consacré un
axe aux activités pastorales et aux
activités
d'élevage alors il est à écrire cette
axe encore parce que c'est normalement
le MAA qui doit l'écrire avec nous bien
sûr et avec les
professionnels mais
euh le le thème de cet axe va être de
reconnaître l'impact des activités
pastorales sur les écosystèmes et c'est
la première fois qu'on va se poser ce
type de question et sur les acte et sur
l'aménagement en général des
territoires donc et ce sera un axe
spécifique sur les quatre de du PNA 4e
axe c'est un axe sur la
gouvernance mais pour la première fois
là
encore la gouvernance va se décliner à
un
échelon au-delà de l'Hexagone puisque le
préfet
coordonateur et moi qui suis son
délégué nous
allons
organiser non seulement des rencontres
avec l'ensemble des pays
voisins pour échanger mais pas
simplement pour échanger mais aussi
pour engager une coopération
opérationnelle
actuellement dans le Jura nous
partageons trois meutes sans doute deux
certainement trois sans doute avec les
Suisses or nous les traitons
complètement différemment et sans réelle
concertation donc à l'intérieur
de ce PNA se dessine une comp alors pas
une coopération européenne parce que
pour l'instant on a on parle pas avec
les Polonais mais on va parler quand
même avec les Suisses les Italiens les
Espagnols les Allemands les
Autrichiens et une fois encore pour
conduire une coopération opérationnelle
pour l'instant les loups qui sont en
France sont de souche
italique nous partageons cette souche
avec
le avec le les la Suisse et
l'Italie mais il est il est très
probable que la connexion avec la souche
hispanique va se faire prochainement et
il est très
probable que la connexion avec la
souche dite
germanique se fera aussi très rapidement
puisqu'on a déjà en fait un loup qui est
de cette
souche deux pour ne pas être trop long
trois points sur ces quatre axes qui qui
sont les points qui ont focalisé la
ttention premièrement j'y reviens on
nous demande de modifier la méthode
d'évaluation des
effectifs de telle sorte à ce que ce qui
s'est passé en 2023 ne se répète pas et
que nous
disposions d'un chiffre et d'un seul au
cours d'une
année l'année 2023 pour celui qui gère
c'est-à-dire moi le protocole de tir a
été une année
horribiliste puisque il a
fallu il a fallu réformer complètement
la gestion des tirs pour bah pour
utiliser toutes nos capacités de tir qui
se sont modifié au 15 septembre au 15
septembre donc un chiffre et un
seul deuxème point et ça c'est majeur le
PNA nous
demande
d'étudier les avantages et les
inconvénients les conditions de
possibilité et les avantages et les
inconvénentss d'une modif du statut
du c'est-à-dire d'envisager
d'envisager de modifier un stat enfin de
passer d'un statut strictement protégé à
un statut d'espèces
protégé alors c'est ce qui a soyons
clair c'est c'est ce qui a conduit les
associations de protection de la nature
à quitter la table
mais en tout cas c'est inscrit c'est
quelque chose que nous devons faire au
cours du
PNA deè deuxè point qui concerne l'axe 2
et qui a aussi focalisé
l'intention le
PNA demande au ministère de
l'agriculture et au préfet coordonateur
avec le préfet
coordonateur d'étudier enfin plus
qu'étudier de
proposer un statut pour le chien de
protection statut qui devrait être
malgré la
résistance soyons clair de nombre de
direction
ministériell statut qui devrare de
nature
législative pourquoi parce qu'on avait
deux
options soit on faisait de du bricolage
réglementaire et ça n'aboutissait pas à
grand-chose soit on donnait
véritablement un cadre juridique au
chien de protection qui deviendrait
chien de travail ça ça pourrait régler
des questions qui aujourd'hui se enfin
empoisonne les toutes les communes les
questions de
divagation les questions
d'aboiement il il y a un juge qui a
trouvé bon de de d'imposer des colliers
anti-aboiement à à des
Patou ce qui est quand même et M
connaître les moyens
de mais des questions aussi qui vont qui
empoisonn ou vont empoisonner ou pourrai
empoisonner la vie des éleveurs
notamment sur les questions de 10 CPE de
chenil au bout de 10 chiens il faut que
vous AZ un un certain nombre
de un Chenile avec des conditions bien
particulières les questions
et toutes les questions qui pourrai
régler
aujourd'hui les conflits qui sont non
seulement des conflits avec les
promeneurs mais qui sont des conflits à
l'intérieur des
villages et qui ne cessent d'augmenter
euh et dernier point qui a focalisé
l'attention mais je pense que je vous
répondrai à vos questions c'est la
modification du protocole de tir on nous
demandait la fusion al vous saz qu'il y
a un tir de défense simple et un tir de
défense renforcé on nous demandait la
fusion les enfin les juristes nous l'ont
refusé et en fait on a fait autrement
c'est qu'on a dit pour un tir de défense
simple aujourd'hui il n'est
possiblefin il n'y a qu'un tireur
possible alors que pour le tir de
défense renforcée on peut avoir jusqu'à
10 tireurs
demain pour le tir de défense simple il
y aura deux tireurs possibles par l'eau
par l'eau VO
sous certaines
conditions globalement c'est quand même
effacé en grande partie la différence
entre tir de défense tir de défense
renforcé on a aussi amélioré les
conditions de
tir saz aujourd'hui on devait même les
louftiers devaient éclairer la cible
avant de
tirer on a considéré que les louftiers
disposaient d'un armement suffisant pour
éviter des la cible et de rater et de
rater le tir ce qui était ce qui était
parfois le
cas et nous avons en
revanche alors ça c'est ce ne sera pas
ce ne sera possible que pour les
louftiers non pas pour les éleveurs ou
les chasseurs en revanche pour les
éleveurs et les chasseurs nous leur
avons permis de disposer d'un matériel
d'observation pas de tir mais
d'observation noct
en considérant que n'importe qui peut
aller acheter un une caméra thermique au
coin de la rue mais que curieusement les
les éleveurs et les chasseurs pouvaient
pas s'en servir dans les opérations de
dans les opérations de tir voilà je vais
pas être plus long madame la Présidente
je répondrai bien évidemment aux
questions euh qui pourrai m'être posées
merci Monsieur le Préfet déjà de ces
donc présentations des principales
mesures du plan national loup je cède la
parole à Monsieur Balic maire du Vernet
qui représente la Fédération nationale
des communes pastorales c'est à vous
merci madame la
Présidente votre micro et plus voilà
merci madame la Présidente la
parole je salue les mesdames les Sénat
messieurs les sénateurs présents qui se
qui s'intéresse aux questions de
l'économie
pastorale alors je représente madame
lebof Denise lebof qui est mare
effectivement d'une commune des altes
maritime qui malheureusement n'a pas pu
se présenter me demander de le
faire donc je représente la Fédération
des communes pastorale qui est une
fédération de communes pas d'élus donc
nous nous défendons des territoires des
territoires communaux alors c'est vrai
que le noyau de la Fédération il est
animé par essentiellement des communes
pastorales du Sud-Est qui se sont
étendus ensuite à la
Corse à la région aux régions du sud
Pyréné également le
langdoc et qui progressivement étend
dans notre action sur les communes des
vauges ENF tout bien sûr les les savoir
alors cette fédération bien sûr cette
association est née dans les années 80
imaginer de l'rivée des loups
euh qui a été pour nous un
véritable si vous voulez coup de tonner
dans nos dans nos zones pastorales
d'autant plus qu'à l'époque ça a été mal
vécu dans la mesure on est et moi je le
suis toujours hein je suis un très vieil
élu je suis toujours convaincu qu'ils
ont
été introduit artificiellement voilà
j'en suis convaincu vousenl pas moi j'ai
des je peux vous donner des des
témoignages
chose que j'ai
vu donc c'est d'autant moins accepté et
ça a véritablement Boué bouleveré notre
mode de vie moi j'ai vécu je suis je
vous l'ai dit un ancien élu j'ai vécu à
peu près 25 ans tranquille de 77 82 83
et puis ma vie de mère a changé depuis
83 je vis plus la même manière il faut
dire je suis le maire d'une petite
commune pastorale qui est un lieu
d'accueil de la transuance
depuis des temps anciens je pense depuis
l'Antiquité qui est pratiqué on vit en
symbiose
avec nos pâturages on accueille des
troupau au vin et des troppaux beau vin
actuellement ceux qui j'y reviendrai
commen à poser certains problèmes avec
le loup et donc je suis un de ceux qui
sont à l'origine de la création de cette
de cette fédération enfit une une
association régionale puis qui é Vune
fédération nationale alors bien entendu
la fédération en deux mots s'occupe du S
pastoralisme des bergers la formation
Berg euh on essaie de travailler pour
qu'il y ait un statut de
berger euh vous appliquez le code du
travail à un berger c'est pas simple il
y a tout le problème des cabanes qui est
essentiel vous n'avez pas de bon berger
si vous n'avez pas une une cabane
confortable
et là-dessus il faut que vous mettiez
l'accent pour aider les communes et
pourquoi pas aussi les éleveurs privés
moi je représente des communes pour
améliorer leur cabane et faire en sorte
que les bergers vivent dans des
conditions satisfaisantes et on a du on
a des bien entendu des soucis pour les
pour les financés alors c'est assez bien
financé on arrive à 80 % de subvention
régional européenne mais il y a pas
suffisant de finance actuellement en
région il y a y a une liste attend de
300 cabanes pastorales donc c'est c'est
c'est quand même assez important et puis
euh bien entendu nous il y a le silv
pastoralisme qui pour nous est important
on a des tas de zones qui s'en sauvagent
pour rien et que dans la mesure où l'ONF
nous dit il y a des arbres qui ont
poussé depuis 30 ans mais c'est soumis
de plein de forer ce qui est pas vrai
d'ailleurs il faudrait faire évoluer
sans doute la législation à ce niveau-là
c'est perdu pour tout le monde sont pas
des forêts qui ont des arbres que un
intérêt forestier et dans des zones qui
ensuite sont fermées au au pastoralisme
faut un peu oublier qu'on a demandé aux
zones rurales après la
guerre de venir remplir les les usines
d'abord nourir la la France qui était
détruite mais également de venir
travailler dans les usines on a vidé les
zones rurales ben ça s'est traduit par
une désertification qu'il faut
aujourd'hui compenser parce que on a de
nombreux éleveurs et jeunes éleveurs qui
cherent ch du pâurage qui cherche de
l'espace et ça il faut absolument
trouver de l'espace donc c'est une je
suis convaincu qu'il y a des des des
surfaces énormes il y a pour qu'on
puisse reconquérir des zones
pastorales sur des zones qui sont
complètement abandonnées et
puis on est intervenu nous également
dans tous ces dossier dont je vous parle
les a soutenus et on on a édité parce
qu'on pense que la question notamment du
pastoralisme passera par l'éducation et
la Fédération des communes pastorales a
édité un ouvrage qui s'appelle zip chien
de berger qui est destiné aux enfants
des écoles primaires pour les
sensibiliser à la vie pastorale et avec
l'idée éventuellement de trouver des des
vocations comme futur
berger alors au niveau du je vais être
bref au niveau des des problèmes
on est confronté donc depuis l'arrivée
du loup alors il y a l'abandon zone
pastorale il faut que vous sachiez qu'il
y a des zones euh pasastoral sont
complètement abandonné où les bergers ne
vont plus le risque de prédation est
trop fort on peut rien faire contre le
loup il y a également les conflits
d'usage et là il y a un conflit d'usage
c'est compliqué entre les les chiens de
protection et les touristes c'est c'est
quasiment insoluble on finira par avoir
des zones pastorales interdites aux
promeneurs c'est quand même c'est quand
même triste alors ça veut dire que on
éloigne les éleveurs du reste de la
population parce que c'est sûr que la
population urbaines les problèmes du
loup pour eu c'est pas leur problème et
alors c'est un lieu un moyen peut-être
de de de mieux faire connaître le
l'activité pastorale aux urbains par le
par le le tourisme que nous on appelle
même le le le tourisme
pastoral
et ce conflit d'usage est de plus en
plus prenant et il y a énormément de de
mères qui viennent vers nous pour dire
comment faire comment comment peut-on
régler la question alors et j'en aurais
terminé avec cette intervention
préliminaire mais je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions puisque j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'ai 45 ans de d'expérience de
maire euh donc du pastoralisme d'autant
plus que j'ai orienté ma commune j'ai
refusé de faire une station de ski il y
a une trentaine d'années euh pour
privilégier le développement doux le
pastoralisme et le tourisme autour du
pastoralisme donc ça'empêche pas que la
commune est hôtel camping et que elle
soit égit qu'elle soit fréquentée c'est
un choix qui a été fait je suis prêt à
à donc à témoigner àre compte cette
expérience et si cela vous intéresse
au point que dans ma commune j'ai réglé
le problème de la du conflit
d'usage en faisant les bergers sont des
agents communaux alors il y a un
contexte particulier il y a pas de
groupement on s'est toujours opposé à ce
qu'il a un groupement pastoral on se dit
si on donne ça à parce que c'est le plus
facile pour une commune don pastoral se
débrouill eux ils adorent ça ils
touchent les subventions ils se débrou
ils font leur leur cuisine ça marche
assez bien je sais qu'on est la seule
commune des Alpes de l'ARCAL peintre
dans cette situation mais ça peut servir
d'exemples à d'autres donc comme on a
des pâturages communaux on a des agents
communaux qui sont desbergés alors c'est
pas facile à gérer vous
imaginez qu'une collectivité locale et
des communaux bergers le code du travail
la réglementation mais on le fait pour
quelle raison c'est pas pour le plaisir
de le faire c'est que le berger il a une
domission il garde ce sont des bergers à
qui ont demandé à qui ont demande
d'accueillir les
touristes donc ça règle le problème
c'est c'est comme si on faisait des AG
des des parcs régionaux nationaux
d'bergers ce serait très bien la
première condition qu'on demand agent de
parc c'est d'être berger vous voz que à
mon avis les choses changerai et pas pas
d'être en technocrate donc moi j'ai
réglé la contradiction de cette
manière-là bon ça peut se faire
autrement mais je serai euh r si vous
souhaiter de vous faire part de cette
expérience parce que parce qu'elle
fonctionne et euh euh alors il y a un
élément nouveau que moi j'avais jamais
vu c'était bon habituel je vous dis
depuis une trentaine d'années les
attaques de Lou trop au de
mouton qui sont effectivement
dramatiques pour les éleveurs qui font
que aujourd'hui il y a un pâturage qu'on
abandonne le le 8 août alors qu'avant
l'abandonné début
septembre à cause du problème que vous
connaissez des des louves qui apprennent
à leouvetau à chasser à la fin août
début septembre et nous on a un
phénomène qui est nouveau c'est le fait
que nous on prend en pension des des
beauauins on a un Troppau de 300 beauins
et les loups maintenant les les meutes
s'attaque au beauvin puis les les les
méthodes de d'attaque des mamouthes hein
euh il y a toutes les méthodes attaque
le vautre au fa habitué de temps en
temps il y a il y a un voie après la la
naissance qui disparaissait bon c'est
pas c'est pas dramatique mais
aujourd'hui c'est on envoie les beau
vins euh dans dans les ravins et vous
savez ce qu'est un beau vin une vache
dans la montagne
vous savez que les brouvin ne March qu'à
l'horizontal
quand il marche à la descente ou à la
montée c'est pas pas à pas comme un
enfant de 1 an donc vous
imaginez une fois qu'ils ont découvert
ça dans la dans dans la me alors ensuite
il enseigne et on finit nous vous parliz
du problème économique je réfléch en dis
mais où est-ce qu'il y a un problème
économique qui est majeur nous le
pâturage puisquon prend des beaux vins
en estive à peu près 100 € l'estive
garder s enfin tout est tout est compris
et ben il y a des éleveurs qui veulent
plus nous envoyer leur
vache donc nous comment on fait et et
autant ça je peux je suis je suis témoin
il y a une grande efficacité parce que
nous soutenons iussi énormément les
louftiers ils sont d'un dévouement alors
il y a un problème de statut bon ce sont
des gens qui sont des bénévoles ils sont
pas assez considérés mais moi je peux
vous dire qu'ils sont efficaces vous
avez une attaque que vous savez vous
avez des loups qui attaquent sur un
pâurage euh à partir du moment où le le
préfet nous a don autorisation de tir
vous envoyez des un loutier je peux vous
dire que lunette thermique c'est réglé
le loup il a aucune chance c'est que le
loup est un gibier ça veut dire que loup
passe toujours au mêmes endroits donc ça
c'est et il y a ça et deuxièmement ce
dont il se méfie pas c'est la nuit il
est convaincu que la nuit il échappe au
contrôle de l'homme partirù vous AZ lett
thermique c'est
fini et c'est pour ça que les les les
écolos poussé pour que on on éclaire si
vousz du jour au loup vous vous
l'attrapez jamais par contre la nuit il
se laisse sa voir donc au niveau des au
niveau des des bvins c'est ce que je
vous disais on n pas de méthode on sait
pas comment on va faire
et pour pour 20 puis j'en ai terminé
avec cette cette observation on arrive à
peu près à s'en sortir vous avez de bons
bergers alors ça ça devient de plus en
plus difficile d'un vieux berger qui
s'occupe bien de son troupeau qui il y
arrive avec des avec des chiens de
protection par contre pour le les les
beau vins alors je reviens à ce que
disait Monsieur le Préfet référent c'est
vrai que on a vu peut-être une baisse de
nombre de victimes mais sur les au vins
et j'aimerais voir comment ça va se
passer pour les beau vins et qu'est-ce
qu'on va
faire on peut pas mettre un chien Patou
derrière chaque beau vin mais c'est pas
possible c'est je je sais pas comment
les choses vont se dérouler enfin nous
et j'en ai terminé notre position c'est
de dire euh ben que le ministre m'a
répondu vous rêvez mais nous notre
position des communes pastorales c'est
de dire il y a des zones pastorales qui
sont incompatibles ave la présence du
loup Point Bar bon après c'est tout un
c'est tout un débat tant qu'on arrivera
pas là mais c'est le Pastor de toute
façon qui sera perdant ça ça peut pas
être autrement je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monie donc on
termine ce premier tour de table avec
Monsieur Dex ingénieur forestier
honoraire et président de l'association
forêt
méditerranéenne merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs j'aimerais vous
apporter un peu de la beauté de
l'oxygène de nos forêts j'aimerais bien
sûr vous
parler de cette pratique ancestrale
qu'est le troupeau enforêt qu'il s'agit
de moderniser aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous faire partager ma conviction que le
silvoastoralisme est un outil puissant
d'entretien de protection et de
valorisation des espaces forestiers
méditerranéens bien sûr mais au-delà de
la zone méditerranéenne également
qu'est-ce que le
syvoastoralisme c'est une combinaison de
pratiques de gestion forestière et
d'élevage extensif et dans les 2 ans où
nous avons travaillé sur ce sujet à
l'association forêt méditerranéenne nous
avons confirmé que cette combinaison de
pratique
est bénéficiaire pour la forêt pour le
troupeau pour la biodiversité et donc
pour le territoire pour la forêt c'était
pas évident à faire vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente les forestiers sont
dubitatifs sur le troupeau dans la forêt
les animaux vont me boulotter tous les
petits plan d'avenir pour la forêt le
troupeau peut-être un atout notamment
dans les phases de jeune peuplement où
le passage des animaux bien conduit par
un bon berger monsieur Balic
absolument va permettre de réduire la
densité des des jeunes plants et semis
en Corse ils utilisent cette pratique
dans la régénération du palarico
ou le troupeau va passer au début de la
régénération et consommer les êtres ou
les chaînes vertes qui ne sont pas les
sens d'avenir et les petits pains s'en
développent beaucoup mieux on peut
trouver comme ça des exemples où bien
conduit encore une fois le troupeau va
aider le forestier dans sa tâche de
restauration de régénération de la forêt
bien sûr et là ça ne souffre pas débat
tout le monde convient que le trou
troupau est un allié pour la défense de
la forêt contre l'incendie en maintenant
des parcelles débroussaillées et ça
marche pour le troupeau dès lors qu'à la
bande des broussaillers on ajoute une
zone de renfort qui va permettre aux
animaux de trouver toute la diversité la
quantité d'alimentation dont ils ont
besoin avantage pour la forêt avantage
pour le troupeau je crois que j'ai pas
besoin d'y rester longtemps en été
notamment c'est sous les arbres que les
animaux vont trouver de l'ombre et un
peu de fraîcheur et c'est sous les
arbres que l'herbe est plus verte et
c'est aussi dans la
forêt madame singl a dit tout à l'heure
que les animaux vont trouver une
ressource ligneuse les grosses bouchées
de feuillage qui complètent bien
l'alimentation des animaux pour la
biodiversité la question a été posée
mais oui la réponse est aussi positive
par la divers cité des formations
forestières plus ou moins boisé que l'on
va trouver par la conservation d'arbres
morts par des points d'eau et tout ça
cette mosaïque de paysage est favorable
à la biodiversité pour le territoire
c'est la résultante de tout ça une forêt
mieux protégée mieux animée une activité
économique de la vie remise dans des
territoires qui sont à abandonner depuis
des dizaines d'années souvent à la suite
de la déprise agricole et pastorale donc
un bilan très positif développons ça
pourquoi ça coince parce que on n pas
tellement d'opérations à succès à
montrer des travaux d'ordre technique
ont été menés pour définir le le
programme le plan pastoral pour les
animaux mais on se rend compte que à ce
regard technique à cette façon de
regarder les wagons d'un train on n'a
pas ajouté le regard sur la locomotive
pour tirer le train et nous avons
identifié un certain nombre de
propositions je n'en cite que trois la
première c'est celle du territoire du
projet de territoire comme tout ce qui
touche à la forêt il faut privilégier
l'action au niveau d'un territoire de
projet piloté par les élus par le maire
ou par le président de l'Inter
communalité rassemblant l'ensemble des
acteurs qui vont partager un constat un
état des lieux et bâtir ensemble un
programme d'action les chartes
forestières de territoire que la
sénatrice madame Loisier connaît bien
sont un un modèle une façon de faire et
dans ce projet de territoire auquel on
espère que tous les acteurs vont adhérer
en se disant qu'ils n'y trouveront pas
tout ce qu'ils souhaitent mais une
quantité suffisante pour y venir
intégrons un ou des projets localisés
silvoau pastorau qui vivront en
combinaison les uns avec les autres et
parce qu'ils seront plus nombreux
pourront travailler à la mise en place
d'une filière de valorisation des
produits qui permettra de rémunérer le
travail des éleveurs on a vu cet exemple
dans l'éau commune de Lunas où un très
joli travail a été fait par un éleveur
qui avec d'autres s'est regroupé pour
mettre en place une boucherie
charcuterie ils vendent tous leurs
produits transformés comme ça on a vu ça
aussi dans le Larzac où une action
collective très importante a été mise et
constitue de et donne de bons résultats
le projet de territoire les élus ont un
rôle moteur à jouer le deuxème axe j'ai
dit le mot à l'instant avec le Larzac
c'est celui du collectif il faut que les
acteurs se regroupent pour travailler
ensemble et dans le
Larzac à la suite de tout le combat qui
a été mené pendant les années 70 les
acteurs impliqués sont restés unis et
ardents ensemble pour vivre au pays et
valoriser les ressources du pays et ils
ont mis toute une série d'outils
collectifs en place pour répondre aux
questions ordinaire celle de la vente
des produits par pour essayer d'obtenir
un meilleur prix qu'une grande structure
agricole bien connue du côté de
Rockfort avait tendance à à réduire ou
pour traiter les questions de soins aux
animaux et cetera un travail très
exemplaire très intéressant le collectif
et une idée que nous avons faite et que
je vous livre est que une partie des
subventions qui sont versées par l'État
la Région et l'Europe et qui sont
indispensables faute de quoi la faire
s'effondre pourrait être versé à ce
collectif pour l'aider à mettre en place
ses outils collectifs bien sûr il reste
des subventions individuelles mais des
subventions collectives ça serait aussi
une façon de pousser dans ce sens le
trisème axe de progrès c'est celui de
l'accompagnement on est face à des
questions délicates qui mettent en en
action des acteurs qui ont des cultures
très différentes il faut un
accompagnement il faut un accompagnement
au niveau de ces structures
intercommunales qui vont porter les
projets auprès de l'élu des animateurs
qui ont à la fois des connaissances
techniques sur l'ensemble des sujets
mais ils ont pas besoin d'être des
spécialistes mais ils connaissent un peu
le sujet et ils connaissent aussi les
techniques d'animation de communication
et cetera pour garder l'aiguillon qui va
permettre aux acteurs de travailler
ensemble c'est un point très important
il faut des aides pour pour que dans ces
structures de territoire il y ait des
animateurs et qui restent dans le temps
au niveau des organismes techniques on a
cité l'ONF le
CRPF les organismes techniques pastoraux
comme le Serpa monpaca ou bien la
chambre régionale d'agriculture en
Occitanie il faut là aussi qu'il y ait
des spécialistes du sujet et qui
puissent aller auprès des éleveurs pour
les aider à évoluer et à monter leur
projet et enfin très important et là le
fonctionnaire à la retraite que je suis
est douloureux de le dire et de le
constater dans nos DDTM dans nos DRAF
dans nos dral on a plus de personnel
compétent pour accompagner toutes ces
actions il faut que l'on remette de la
capacité d'ingénierie et d'assistance
d'aide à l'innovation auprès de tous ces
acteurs voilà quelques points de progrès
sur lesquels il nous faut travailler
j'en ai quelques autres je les dirai
éventuellement tout à l'heure et si la
question est posée de propositions
législativ ou réglementaire je pourrais
en suggérer aussi merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup donc on va
ouvrir les questions donc comme je l'ai
annoncé je vais d'abord laisser la
parole à nos deux collègues à la fois de
Haute Savoie et de sa voix Sylviane Noël
et Martine Berté
Sylviane merci madame la Présidente et
merci mesdames madame messieurs pour vos
témoignages et vos propos sur ce sujet
de la prédation et de son impact sur
notre agriculture pastoral qui au-delà
de son rôle nourricier joue un rôle
majeur dans l'entretien et le façonnage
de nos territoires de montagne vous
l'avez rappelé le plafond des loups à
prélevé dépend du nombre de loups
comptabilisés le nouveau plan loup
simplifie le régime des tirs notamment
les tirs de défense simple et c'est
heureux néanmoins nous rencontrons
concrètement des difficultés dans la
gestion de ces prélèvements qui est
complexifié par le décalage de la
période d'estive qui est très différent
d'un massif à l'autre he si on prend le
cas des Alpes Maritimes et bien cette
période d'estive s'ouvre très tôt dans
la saison alors qu'en Savoie et en Haute
Savoie il faut attendre souvent la fonte
des neiges sur fin mai début juin
et
donc si je prends l'exemple concret de
ce qui s'est passé cette année au début
de l'année 2023 le plafond était fixé à
174 loups pour le prélèvement au début
de la saison à l'issue du premier
comptage au regard donc des 900 loups
comptabilisés au début de l'été Monsieur
le Préfet vous vous êtes inquiété du
nombre de loups déjà prélevés assez
élevé donc vous avez apparemment demandé
au préfet de ralentir un petit peu ce
niveau de prélèvement et ensuite est
intervenu le deuxième comptage qui a
relevé encore ce nombre de loups et donc
vous avez demandé au contraire
d'accélérer un petit peu pour qu'on
puisse remplir enfin bref à un moment où
on en avait plus vraiment besoin
malheureusement donc on a un espèce de
step and Go qui est très difficile à
gérer sur le terrain qui est assez
néfaste pour la gestion de cette
prédation donc ma proposition c'est
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il
serait nécessaire de territorialiser de
déconcentrer davantage ses prélèvements
en fixant un plafond pour l'année avec
des prélèvements qui pourraient être
différents d'une zone à l'autre ce qui
permettrait plus de souplesse et une
meilleure prise en compte de la réalité
des territoires je vous remercie Martine
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Préfet madame et et
Messieurs alors le loup en savoir alors
peut-être le pastoralisme tout d'abord
en savoir comme cela a été dit donc
c'est bien sûr de la viande des fromages
des nombreuses AOP IGP tout cela fait
vivre une économie fait vivre des gens
sur place au pays et c'est de l'emploi
c'est également l'entretien de nos
pistes de ski pour ce tourisme divivers
que nous
avons le pastoralisme donc est
indispensable à notre économie et nous
souhaitons vraiment pouvoir le protéger
le la prédation c'était 500 constats
d'attaque en 2023 300 dossiers pour 3,3
million d'euros
d'indemnisation plus 840 forfaits
d'entretien de chien de
protection pour 2023 des coûts très
importants sur la prédation avec des
subventions qui pourraient être utilisé
de façon totalement différente par nos
agriculteurs qui en ont bien besoin pour
développer leurs activités donc en
savoise le problème que nous rencontrons
alors certes il y a des attaques d'ovin
très très nombreuses mais c'est vraiment
ce problème d'attaque sur les bovins qui
s'intensifi or les AOP que nous avons
sont des
AOP surtout sur des fromages avec du
lait de vache donc c'est très grave pour
notre économie il y a eu des
expérimentations qui ont été mis en
place dans notre département des tirs de
défense simples sans besoin d'attaque
préalable des colliers défarrouchement
du loup pour les ins comme pour les
beauauins et des chiens de protection
sur les élevages bovvin je voulais
savoir si ces expérimentations vont se
développer se généraliser passer du
stade expérimentation à un stade tout à
fait normal
classique ça c'était ma première
question et ma deuxème question sur le
classement du loup quelles démarches
vont être engagé par la France pour ce
classement dans quel délai voilà est-ce
que des choses sont déjà en route alors
juste une petite anecdote pardon pour
finir madame la Présidente pas pour pour
très longtemps mais pour parler
effectivement de cette nécessité
d'encourager les jeunes éleveurs à
reprendre des exploitation ou de suivre
dans la lignée de leurs parents je
voyais ce matin un reportage sur la Miss
France la nouvelle Miss France agricole
qui est une jeune fille qui élève des
brebis j'ai trouvé ça absolument
formidable elle était enthousiaste par
ce qu'elle faisait et j'aimerais bien
qu'on puisse les encourager encore plus
ces jeunes pu ah moi je savis même pas
qu'il y avait des Miss France agricole
mais bon voilà on apprend tout peut-être
déjà pour répondre à nos deux collègues
je vous laisse la parole peut-être
Monsieur le Préfet et ensuite nos
invités complèteront si besoin
oui merci madame la Présidente alors sur
la
question sur la question de la
différenciation c'est une question
récurrente l'année
2023 n'est pas une année an
exemplaire c'est loin d'être le cas
parce qu'il a fallu comme vous l'avez
rappelé même la sénatrice
gérer
deux deux évaluations
d'effectifs et
à avec des écarts très
importants ce qui m'a conduit
effectivement en début d'année
à de enfin à ralenti le rythme des tirs
qui devenait très conséquent au regard
du plafond alors qui é un plafond
162 mais pas
seulement qui parce que le rythme des
tirs était un rythme des tir qui
se se concentrait sur deux ou trois
départements or mon rôle c'est aussi de
garantir la possibilité de se protéger
à tous les départements au cours de
l'année or comme vous l'avez à juste
titre rappelé il y a des
décalages donc c'est aussi mon rôle
c'est pour ça que il se
maintiendra c'est aussi mon rôle
de de préserver les équilibres entre les
départements néanmoins attribuer des
quotas parce que ça reviendrait à ça à
tel ou tel territoire ce serait figé le
système parce que vous avez actuellement
aujourd'hui des départements qui ont
encore enfin qui utilisent des capacités
de
tir que d'autres n'ont pas pu ou ou
n'ont pas eu le besoin
d'utiliser donc par exemple actuellement
dans les Alpes Maritimes dans le Var
dans les Alpes de HauteProvence
ben on continue à tirer parce que il y a
des attaques et parce qu'il y y en a il
y a la
nécessité si on avait si on avait mis
des des quotas au regard de la prédation
et cetera il y a au moins de département
qui ne pourrai plus tirer
d'où la doctrine qui prévaut c'est on
maintient un plafond national mais avec
une instance régulatrice en revanche en
en l'occurrence c'est moi pour que tous
puissent avoir d'abord qu'on puisse
maintenir des capacités de tir tout au
long de l'année pour
tous et que l'on puisse servir ceux qui
sont les plus attaqués
euh voilà en en alors en dialogue
constant avec les préfets puisque je
réunis les DDT enfin là euh durant les
les les qu derniers mois je réunissais
les DDT toutes les les semaines et là je
pense qu'on va passer à un rythme de
réunion avec préfet et DDT tous les
mois parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue constant avec et les DDT et les
préfets voire même les louftiers si si
cela est
possible sur les expérimentations sur
sur
bovin le PNA
prévoit qu'il estib
d'attribuer sur des territoires
spécifiques là où la prédation est forte
c'est chez vous c'est notamment chez
vous mais pas seulement dans le dou et
dans d'autres départements et bien qu'il
est possible d'attribuer des
autorisation de tir dérogatoire sans
attaque
préalable et sans mise en uvre de moyens
de
protection alors soyons
clair ça passe ou ça
casse parce que
juridiquement juridiquement on est dans
un dans une zone
grise pour
l'instant les associations ne nous ont
pas
attaquer sans doute parce qu'elle ne se
sentait pas assez fort et sans doute
parce qu'elle reconnaissait la nécessité
d'intervenir sur ces
territoire ceci dit la
donne la donne a changé c'est que la
relation avec les associations elle est
aujourd'hui
différente je ne sais pas si le juge est
interrogé je ne sais pas ce qu'il
dira et il y a un débat à l'intérieur
de actuellement du
gouvernement
qui voudrait que nous allions plus
loin c'est-à-dire que ce ne soit pas
simplement sur des
territoires spécifiques mais que ce soit
pour tous les élevages
bovvin bien évidemment élevage bovin
dans une zone qui fait l'objet de d'un
risque de
prédation le problème c'est là aussi un
un problème
juridique parce que si nous sommes
attaqués et si alors ce sera sans doute
une circulaire mais si la circulaire
tombe on reviendra à mon avis à à la
position excantée c'estdaà rien sur les
bovins voilà il faut bien mesurer le
risque juridique il faut bien pour
l'instant on a ça on c'est plus de
l'expérimentmentation on va on va
l'étendre mais sur des zones où il y a
où la prédation est très très forte et
il faut faire attention à de à ce que
enfin à ce risque juridique qui pourrait
vraiment nous
handicapé qui veut continuer peut-être
ou non non non mais je parle déjà nos
invités non rien à dire à cette à ce
stade alors on va prendre trois
questions Bernard buit Olivier Ritman et
an chin Larcher merci présidente merci à
nos intervenants pour leur clarté de
leurs propos et puis leur engagement sur
le pastoralis dans nos montagnes moi
j'aurais une question à Monsieur le
Maire concernant le statut du berger
employé communal donc si j'ai bien
compris c'est un fonctionnaire
territorial vous l'embaucher à l'année
qu'est-ce qu' fait l'hiver mais bon
après j'ai d'autres questions une
question madame là par rapport à
l'évolution des in actuellement moi chez
moi on me dit que le cours de la viande
auovine a fortement augmenté au cours
des deux ou trois dernières années ce
qui était pas le cas précédemment donc
c'est plutôt encourageant est-ce que
vous constater au niveau français une
stagnation de la consommation de viande
ovine ou une augmentation je sais pas
comment ça évolue on importe toujours
beaucoup d'ovin est-ce qu'on en manque
autant que ce qu'on croit ou pas et puis
derrière j'avais une question concernant
les abattoirs parce que chez moi ce qui
remonte sur les territoires c'est un
besoin en abattoir alors il semblerait
qu'une solution pourrait être les
embattoirs ambulants avec un gros
problème concernant les mes en place et
puis les normes et donc je sais pas
comment ça évolue là-dessus parce que
c'est très difficile à implanter et
après c'est assez compliqué à suivre et
puis je voulais vraiment remercier
Monsieur le Préfet pour sa présentation
du PNA vous avez fait cet exercice en
Drome lundi puisquon était ensemble au
comité loup et ça a été très apprécié
par toutes les parties prenantes et je
crois que les avancées que vous avez
précisé que vous avez reprécisé
aujourd'hui vont dans le bon sens et
semblent vraiment répondre à un besoin
alors j'avais une question pour rapport
à ça je pense qu'il faudra vraiment
qu'on insiste sur la transparence vous
avez évoqué un peu avec le nombre de
loups le méthode de comptage pour
qu'elle soit partagée qu'elle soit
validée par tous et puis pour derrière
qu'on respecte les engagement qu'on a
pris je crois que je vous l'ai déjà dit
lundi mais aujourd'hui c'est une grosse
atteentete de territoire parce que on
voit avec les difficultés les
prélèvements qui sont remontés par les
uns et par les autres on n' pas le
retour on a évoqué tout à l'heure la
date d'E nombre de comptages et puis
derrière ben tout ce que ça engage et
donc je crois que là-dessus il faut
vraiment qu'on anticipe et qu'on
travaille tous ensemble pour pouvoir
avancer sinemain merci merci Bernard
Olivier Ritman oui merci madame la
Présidente Olivier Ritman sénateur de la
haute zone merci Monsieur le Préfet
madame et messieurs pour les propos que
vous avez tenus qui nous éclaircissent
un certain nombre de points je ne peux
qu'appuyer certains propos qui qui qui
qui qui insiste sur l'importance du
pastoralisme sur la protection de nos
forêts et moi qui est commis avec
Anne-Catherine Loisier ici présente
entre autres un rapport sur la
limitation de l'extension et de
l'intensification des feux de forêt et
qui avons rapporté la loi présentée au
mois de juillet on insistait notamment
dans un des articles sur cette
importance capitale si on veut aller au
bout des choses pour protéger nos forêt
du pasteuralisme non moi je voulais
venir sur un autre sujet et ma question
sera assez Brè
euh je parle de de la protection contre
des attaques de loup solitaires dans des
territoires de plaines où il n'y a pas
de meut moi qui suit élu de franchecé la
haute zone le Jura pas dans la zone
auudou au Jura mais dans les zones de
plaines où on a régulièrement notamment
en hiver des passages furtifs mais qui
font d'énormes dégâts de loup solitaire
qui traversent le département et qui au
fur à mesure de leur avancé attaque des
troupeaux notamment au vin
principalement au vin d'ailleurs et qui
font des des dégâts considérables on
n'est pas sur des attaques pour se
nourrir mais des attaques uniquement
entre guillemets je dis bien de jeu euh
et qui laissent des brebis très blessé
des brebis ou des agneaux tués et quand
ça vous arrive sur de la neige je peux
vous dire que ça fait peur quand on voie
ça le matin et une décision est très
lente à être prise les systèmes de
protection mis en place dans les zones
de pastoralisme ne fonctionne pas
puisqu'on est sur un un une une
diversité du pâturage avec des des des
petites parties de troupeau sur des
pâures différentes s'il faut aller
fermer dans des encloss les troupeaux le
soir c'est impossible s'il faut mettre
un chien derrière chaque troupeau c'est
impossible on pouvez avoir jusqu'à 12 15
20 différents troupeaux répartis sur le
parcellaire et et la seule solution
qu'on a trouvé jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est
d'expliquer aux exploitants que tous les
soirs ou au moins que toute la journée
et la nuit ou au moins la nuit ils
enferment l'intégralité de leur troupeau
dans un bâtiment ce qui est impossible à
à réaliser ça met très loin à se décider
pour un abattage le loup est déjà parti
très loin on fait des prélèvements de
poil des rellevés de trac on dit oui
c'est un candidé mais on n'est pas sûr
ça soit un loup donc une décision n'est
pas prise avant 6 mois et au bout de 6
mois on apprend qu'effectivement c'était
un loup alors qu'on a des preuves
photographiques et cetera qui montrent
que c'était bien bon et en attendant
l'indemnisation pour les exploitants est
très difficile à mettre en œuvre parce
qu'il y a pas de mesure de protection
spécifique puisqu'on n pas une zone de
loup donc est-ce qu'il y a une attention
particulière portée sur ce ce genre de
territoire ça arrive régulièrement de
plus en plus notamment en hiver et on a
aucune solution que ça soit au niveau
DDT que ça soit au niveau enfin à tous
les niveaux pour régler ce problème qui
est de plus en plus prignant et qui qui
cause de plus en plus de dégâts à la
fois économique mais aussi psychologique
quand vous retrouvez devant un couple
d'agriculteur d'éleveur auin qui a subi
ce genre d'attaque je peux vous dire que
ça a un impact très fort merci merci
Olivier Anne chinarcher merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Préfet
merci Madame et
Messieurs clairement on on assiste là à
l'opposition à la fois d'une idéologie
d'un côté et de l'autre côté d'une
réalité à la fois
économique qui tend à défendre la
biodiversité et puis surtout vit d'une
tradition ancestrale dans notre
pays si on veut que les choses marchent
il faut que cela repose sur une
transparence et une confiance or
aujourd'hui le problème à vous entendre
Monsieur le Préfet c'est que ce que
redoute l'État c'est le contentieux
or face à une idéologie que l'on connaît
bien qui est défendue par des
associations dont le financement reste
d'ailleurs un jour une question
peut-être qu'il faudra que au Sénat on
se penche sur cette question ces
associations sont puissantes parce que
elles exercent un un fort lobby un fort
lobbying je ne sais pas aujourd'hui si
l'opinion publique se satisferait de
voir en permanence des images d'animaux
qui sont totalement dévastés par des
attaques de loups on ne supporte pas de
voir et de savoir qu'un loup a été tué
mais est-ce qu'on supporterait de voir
des élevages de bovin des élevages
d'ovin saccagés sanguinolant euh bon à
tout simplement abattre lorsqu'ils sont
euh lorsqu'ils ne sont pas encore morts
est-ce qu'on le supporterait donc
quelque part euh quand je vous dis que
tout ça repose sur une confiance c'est
celle de se dire que peut-être que le
comptage euh qui a été bien entendu
contesté depuis des années euh devrait
aujourd'hui être tout à fait transparent
et tout à fait fiable et là-dessus
Monsieur le Préfet vraiment je c'est une
question que je vous pose il y a-t-il
aujourd'hui une véritable volonté de
compter y a-t-il aussi sur le terrain
les effectifs nécessaires je je me pche
vers l'ofb bien sûr est-ce que l'ofb est
présente sur les territoires vous avez
parlé tout tout à l'heure de la ddtt bon
je pense que ici au Sénat nous avons
déjà les réponses mais en attendant de
votre part on aimerait bien savoir si de
la part de l'État cette volonté est là
parce qu'à partir du moment où on saura
exactement l'ampleur de la situation
peut-être qu'on mettra en face des
solutions pour les résoudre merci Anne
alors on va répondre à ces trois
personnes qui ont questionné parce qu'il
y a plusieurs questions dans les
interventions peut-être madame Singla
parce que je crois que Monsieur bu enfin
il y avit quand même quelques questions
qui vous concerernent oui par rapport au
cours de l'agneau effectivement le cours
de l'agneau se porte bien depuis déjà de
2 3 ans euh ce qui est nous ça nous
satisfait complètement en revanche c'est
dû à plusieurs problèmes à la fois
conjoncturelle avec le le brexit au
Royaume-Uni la faiblesse des
importations qui se néozélandaise qui
était liée
à à une sècheresse sans précédent donc
tout ça a fait que la rare areté du
produit a fait monter le prix de
l'agneau français et et c'est tant mieux
c'est pas pour autant qu'on n pas
soucieux notamment des accords de libre
échange et particulièrement celui qui
vient d'être conclu avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande voilà alors on sait
très bien que les contingents
aujourd'hui n'étaient pas remplis hein
puisqu'ils le sont pratiquement qu'à 50
% mais il n'empêche que la
Nouvelle-Zélande a des possibilités de
réactivité que nous n'avons pas à des
prix qui sont qui arrivent quand même à
deux fois et demi moins cher que
l'agneau français et que de suite ça a
un impact sur les cours forcément donc
oui les éleveurs sont inquiets et puis
sur surtout qu'on a l'impression d'être
dans un autre monde on comprend pas on
comprend pas quand on voit l'Union
européenne afficher une décroissance
pour l'élevage à hauteur de 30 % pour
les années à venir et qu'on importe
davantage de viande où est la cohérence
dans tout ça est-ce qu'on nous dit à
nous Français ne produisez plus et on va
en importer davantage euh voilà quoi
donc vous comprenez que ça aussi c'est
difficile à comprendre par les les
éleveurs que nous sommes quoi on se dit
mais mais mais à quoi on joue quoi voilà
donc là là c'est un gros souci mais bon
pour l'instant le cours de l'anau se
maintient et c'est tant mieux euh après
vous avez posé une question sur les
abattoirs vous savez que les abattoirs
souvent bon nombre d'abattoirs ont des
difficultés de rentabilité économique
hein le modèle économique est est pas
bon et et du coup ça les ça les met dans
des situations difficile ou souvent
alors quand ce sont des il y en a pas
beaucoup mais il y a quand même des
abattoirs qui sont publ
et et là ça met ça met évidemment les
les collectivités nous aident et c'est
en mieux pour essayer de conserver ces
outils qui sont absolument
indispensables après mettre des
abattoirs ambulants on se pose des
questions je vous le dis clairement on
est très dubitatif par rapport à ça
parce que on préférerait mettre l'accent
sur les outils et maintenir les les les
petits abattoirs de proximité qui existe
actuellement plutôt que de les plomber
en faisant un abattage ambulant à la
ferme qui va nécessiter et ça on est
très rigoureux là-dessus la présence
quand même d'agents de la DDPP pour
faire toutes les observations
antémortème postmortême et tout ça qui
font que euh je je doute qu'il est des
ressources humaines suffisantes pour
assurer ce service dans les meilleures
conditions voilà c'est pour ça que on
est oui favorable au maintien des
abattoirs de proximité même des petits
abattoirs de proximité qui existent et
qui ont beaucoup de mal à subsister
voilà c'est pas la peine d'aller se
disperser essayons de sauver ce qui
existe voilà pour pour ce qui est des
questions qui me concerernent je pense
monsieur Balic peut-être vous avez été
donc interrogé aussi sur votre
expérimentation ou ce que vous faites
sur votre commune avec le berger il se
trouve que j'ai une expérience au niveau
des petits abattoirs 150 tonnes par an
j'ai rouvert un abattoir je crois que
c'est le seul qui était ouvert en en
France dans les années euh 2000 et je
l'ai géré pendant 20 20 ans à mon avis
dans les zones dans lesquelles le privé
n'arrive pas à faire fonctionner des
laboratoires y compris par l'
intermédiaire de
coopérative pour moi la la le système le
modèle le plus simple c'est l'équipement
est public l'investissement est financé
par le public et les éleveurs par la
redevance qui paye à l'abattoir finance
le fonctionnement et vous laissez pas
rentrer ni un éleveur ni un
professionnel
dans l'abattoir c'est des conseils qui
MT été donnés par tout le monde c'est
vous rentrez dans un hôpital vous allez
pas vous mêler ce qui se passe dans
l'hôpital on voit déjà les problèmes que
ça pose dans les écoles en mant les
parents aux
enseignants là c'est pareil et je peux
vous dire que ça fonctionnera et en
général les régions les départements
tout ça pous les éleveurs comme je leur
disais toujours vous êtes usagers vous
AMZ une bte sur pied on vous donne une
carcasse c'est que la carcasse soit
belle et qu'elle vous cote le moins cher
possible c'est le seul moyen que vous
ayez et ça fonctionne et partout où il y
a des expériences dans lesquelles parce
que je vois très bien je suis plus
président de l'intercommunalité donc
derrière il espèce de de groupement
d'éleveurs qui viennent gérer il font
l'invers de ce qu'il faut alors
connaissez le monde des éleveurs c'est
compliqué à gérer collectivement eux
leur métier c'est de lever des des
moutons et des vaches c'est pas de des
abattoirs c'est un are métier mais si
vous le considérez comme un service
public avec la qualité et le rapport du
prix qui soit correct tout va bien et
les moyens financiers alors pour
répondre à votre question sur le statut
c'est pas des agents territoriaux pensez
bien c'est des contractuels bon alors j'
regarder juridiquement coup de bol la la
convention collective des employés
agricoles il faut moins des contrats de
plus d'un an donc c'est relativement
cool par contre il y a la journée de il
faut une journée de de
repos il faut des conditions
d'hébergement correct et Dieu sait si on
est contrôlé mais sinon c'est c'est
c'est contractuel c'est on pe nous on
les P les bergers je sais pas vous on
les paye 2500 € net par mois et et sur
le marché vous avez des gens qui sont
bergers qui se placent pour les sttive
et ils aiment bien venir se placer
chez une collectivité parce qu'ils sont
sûrs qu'ils seront payés qu' seront bien
traités qui seront parce que c'est bon
c'est un métier difficile m Berg voà et
surtout moi j'ai vu la première chose
qu'il regarde notamment chez les
bergères ce qui est normal ils viennent
d'abord voir le
logement oui ah ça c'est c'est le soir
ils rentrent ils veulent une douche ils
veulent bon on n pas encore à la télé
parce que ça les intéresse pas mais bon
vraiment ils veulent le confort le
frugidère le voilà c'est ils veulent
tout
ça
alors vous
voulez sur les indices
collectés c'est une
nécessité
l'ofb l'ofb nous la
doit et ça fait un an que
j'attends donc ma la patience commence
à disons disons que l'ofb a des a
tendance à effectivementir avait
tendance à répartir ses effectifs selon
désorient ation qui n'était
pas favorable au loup je pense que les
choses sont sont en train de changer
donc on ne rétablira pas la confiance si
on a pas ça vous collectez un indice on
vous on vous doit de que de savoir ce
qu'il est devenu comment il est été
classé comment il a été traité et ça il
le faut
impérativement donc euh je reviendrai
auprès de vous j'espère et j'espère
pouvoir vous dire que que la la la
question est
réglée
sur sur les loups
solitaires
alors c'est c'est effectivement là où en
en
2022 l'accroissement de près de 20 % des
victimes était dû pour 60 %
à des loups solitaires dans en pleain
dans des dans des départements de
colonisation donc c'est c'est dire
l'importance et cette année encore cette
année encore si on avait que les
départements historique on serait à 15 %
de de baisse de la prédation mais il y a
eu lolot il y a
eu l'avyon et il y a eu la sonnéloire et
et la sonnéloire et la Côte d'Or
sonnéloire sonnéloire c'est c'est c'est
près de
300 victimes depuis le début de l'année
on a réussi à tirer de loup en soné noir
mais comment on a fait quelle est la
difficulté vous l'avez vous l'avez tout
à fait souligné monsieur le sénateur le
loup
arrive
euh il d'abord il faut il faut qu'il
soit bien repéré mais ça c'est aussi mon
travail parce que sur l'indemnisation
par exemple il n'est pas normal que
qu'il ait eu des difficultés c'est pas
normal parce que il y a un protocole il
y a les gens de l'ofb qui viennent faire
les constats il y a un protocole et le
doute à supposer qu'il y ait doute le
doute doit profiter à l'éleveur c'est
écrit dans le droit c'est écrit dans le
doigt et et
on va même plus loin si il n'y a par
exemple aucun élément et ça on le trouve
souvent ailleurs que dans la sonéoire
mais vous avez une carcasse vousvez même
plus de boucle les les votour ont fait
le travail mais il y a eu tout autour
des attaques de loup avéré et bien le
doute il doit profiter à
l'éleveur ça je j'insiste auprès de
j'insiste auprès des des des DT qui
n'applique pas toujours nécessairement
immédiatement ce type de ce type de
règle donc ça ça doit
être et si jamais vous voyez des enfin
des des cas n'hésitez pas à m'en faire
part pour que je puisse régler les
choses et l'indemnisation elle se fait
en moins de 125 jours et désormais elle
doit se faire dans moins de 125 jours
c'est écrit à l'intérieur du
PNA vous vous avez un loup solitaire qui
s'installe enfin il s'installe pas le
plus souvent il il a il a il a des des
des mouvements
ératiques et bien évidemment les
élevages ell découvrent la prédation et
ne sont donc pas protégé et dès lors on
n pas la possibilité de don donner les
autorisations de tir
nécessaires donc on a doublé les crédits
d'urgence pour mettre dans la capacité
pour être dans la capacité de financer
les moyens d'urgence notamment les
clôtures
électrifié ça permet d'avoir des
autorisations de tir et c'est ce qu'on a
c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi en
sonir les autorisations de tir nous
permettent de mailler le territoire
alors si le loup divague un peu autour
d'un
territoire plus on a de point de de de
surveillance et mieux on peut le tirer
mais c'est c'est c'est le cas le plus
c'est le cas le plus difficile la louve
du lot on a mis 18 mois à l'avir et et
on l'a eu de cette manière aussi
c'est-à-dire en s'appuyant sur des des
autorisations démultipliant les
autorisations de tir et en s'appuyant
là-dessus et en envoyant les louftiers
et en envoyant aussi la briade c'est
comme ça qu'on peut le
faire dès lors alors c'est c'est c'est
ce que j'ai c'est ce
que je c'est ce que je rappelle aussi à
l'ensemble ce que N on rappelle à
l'ensemble de nos collègues c'est qu'il
faut aller dès lors que il y a attaque
et qu'on a que on a décidé de mettre en
uvre les moyens de protection faut aller
très vite et l'autorisation de tir elle
doit être délivrée dans alors le PNA dit
dans les 48 heur moi j'aurais tendance à
dire dans les 24
he 48 he au
maximum il faut il faut dès lors qu'il y
a une attaque le matin faut que les
louftiers puissent monter le
soir
sur la
question de des madame la sénatrice sur
la question des
euh du contentieux et du
comptage le contentieux on en a pas peur
parce que pour l'instant on les
gagne et les
APN mais enfin faut faut voir quels sont
les moyens comme vous l'avez rappelé
quels sont les moyens des APN moi
lorsque je je suis allé en au Conseil
d'État pour défendre c'était en 2020 un
arrêté l'arrêté
interministériel je me suis retrouvé
devant je donnerai pas le nom de
l'association devant une association
et il y avait six
avocats qui alors je pense je pense que
j'aurais préférer moi recevoir leur
rémunération ce jour-là que la mienne he
estce que là c parce qu'on était au
Conseil d'État on était on était en en
référé suspension je pense que là ils
ont ils ont ils ont des moyens
importants et pourtant ils ont des
moyens importants mais on a réussi sur
les les notamment les arrêtés
d'autorisation de tir dérogatoire on
réussi à défendre puisqu'on n'est pas
annulé et même sur des tirs de
prélèvement parce qu'ils
attaquent systématiquement le tir de
prélèvement
même sur les tirs de prélèvement l'année
dernière il y en a eu il y a eu quatre
tirs de prélèvement autorisés quatre
contentieux quatre succès pour l'État
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut être très
très
attentif sur le
comptage il faut rétablir la confiance
c'est rétablir la transparence et ça on
le doit et une fois encore moi j'ai une
grande impatience pour que enfin on
puisse savoir quand on donne un indice
ce qu'il ADV devient et à quoi il
sert il faut avoir aussi une méthode qui
soit éprouvée la
nôtre ne répond plus exactement
à ce C cette exigence parce que il y a
un écart de plus en plus grand entre ce
le chiffre qui arrive au mois de juin et
qui est basé sur la collecte des
d'indices et puis le le chiffre qui est
consolidé par les analyses génétiques
moi je vais avoir au mois de janvier
deux groupes de travail notamment avec
les les organisations
professionnelles pour se dire on peut
pas continuer comme ça de toute manière
le PNA une fois encore nous demande
d'avoir un seul chiffre et il faut que
ce chiffre il
soit enfin que la méthode soit partagée
et que le chiffre soit fondé
scientifiquement il me semble
aujourd'hui mais je veux pas anticiper
sur un débat que nous aurons avec les
OPA il me semble aujourd'hui que la
génétique pourrait nous donner cette
assise scientifique plus solide à
condition d'avoir des analyses
génétiques intégrales c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a qu'une partie
des indices biologiques qui font l'objet
d'analy génétique il faut que les
analyses soient
exhaustives et ben je j'ai j'ai été voir
parce qu' avec l'ofb que je suis assez
attentivement aujourd'hui euh avec l'ofb
j'ai j'ai eu un débat avec
le avec le le le laboratoire
d'analyse c'est pas c'est pas si cher
que
ça et j'ai demandé à b qui a pu
avoir qui est qui a eu les moyens de le
faire de consolider ses équipes de telle
sorte à ce que on puisse suivre ces
analyses génétiques de manière plus
attentive donc l'ofb il faut faut savoir
que on a réussi quand même à avoir une
nouvelle unité de l'ofb qui a été créé à
Rodz
euh sur Mo de juin je crois
qui est donc une une unité qui va être
dédié à un territoire on aura l'unité de
Gap et on aura cette unité l'unité de
Gap va être spécialisée sur l'arc alpin
cette nouvelle unité va être spécialisée
notamment sur la zone au verg et
pyrénée ce qui va nous permettre donc il
a une augmentation de personnel pas que
je je j'aurais j'en aurais aimé plus
mais bon on a quand même maintenant une
équipe deux équipe qui est constitué et
qui va faire ce que l'ofb doit faire
un bah les tirer là où il le faut dans
des là où les conditions sont
particulières et difficiles et où il
faut former les
louffiers et collecter les données
collecter les indices et ça va nous
permettre d'avoir un meilleur maillage
sur le territoire en sachant que j'ai
souhaité et là aussi l' FB l'a accepté
que l'on
modifie les méthodes de collecte c'est
pas la peine d'aller collecter 10
indices ça
le
l'bled le sait et le répète à juste
titre c'est pas la peine d'aller
collecter 10 indices dans le même
jardin vaut mieux en collecter un ou
deux mais alleer collecter des indices
là où on ne fait pas d'exploration
aujourd'hui on aura sans doute une
meilleure image de la présence du loup
et on aura une meilleure évaluation des
effectifs merci Monsieur le Préfet donc
nous passons à trois nouvelles questions
Daniel salmon Lucien stantion et
Jean-Marc
Boyer merci madame la Présidente merci
Madame et messieurs pour votre
présentation madame présidente vous
l'avez dit dans votre introduction on va
parler de la filière ovine et pas que du
loup donc j'ai d'abord de deux questions
euh on a abordé tout à l'heure la
question euh des traités de libre
échange et des euh des importations de
Nouvelle-Zélande depuis les années 1980
le début de d'ouverture au marché le
chaptel français a perdu 1/3 un/3 de sa
population donc aujourd'hui on on a
redonné 38000 ton je crois euh à la
Nouvelle-Zélande ce sont plusieurs
millions l'équivalent de plusieurs
millions donc de moutons qui sont
importés t tous les ans euh en Europe et
en par particulièrement en France et on
produit plus que la moitié de notre
consommation donc là il y a un vrai
sujet c'est aussi une concurrence
déloyale puisqu'on sait que les
conditions d'élevage ne sont pas les
mêmes en Nouvelle-Zélande que que en
France et avec l'utilisation par exemple
certains d'insecticides euh donc là il y
a vraiment une distorsion de concurrence
et je pense qu'il faudrait s'attaquer à
cela avant de d'ouvrir toujours des
nouvelles possibilités et je pense que
ça c'est eu un cette importation a un
impact considérable sur euh sur notre
élevage autre point euh qu'on n' pas
abordé j'aurais bien voulu avoir euh
vous entendre sur les problématiques de
réchauffement climatique et de
sécheresse également qui amène des
difficultés aussi euh pour le pâurage et
ce que vous pensez de l'agrivoltaïsme
qui est aujourd'hui un élément qui est
apporté en lien avec l'élevage au vin et
qui peut peut-être dans certaines
conditions
améliorer la production d'herbes puisque
il y a c'est un apport d'ombre et puis
sinon je veux pas me défausser parce que
je suis quand même
l'écologiste du
secteur sur le loup
et j'en fais partie euh effectivement
moi je ne suis pas là pourier du tout
les problématiques et les difficultés
engendrées par le loup je suis très
attaché nous sommes très attachés à
l'élevage en France on a besoin de cet
élevage il a façonné nos imaginaires il
a façonné nos paysages et on se doit de
de le conserver après tout est une
question d'équilibre
effectivement le
loup est revenu en France le dernier
loup a été tué en Bretagne un peu plus
tard que dans dans les haut sonone
puisque c'était en 1913 alors c'était
c'est loin mais c'était pas le Moyen-âge
et on a vécu très longtemps avec le loup
donc il y a certainement des équilibres
bien entendu à
trouver Anne Chan Larcher a parlé de la
souffrance des animaux tout à l'heure
effectivement mais tous les animaux
souffrent et ils souffrent également
quand ils vont à l'abattoire et euh
c'est la question de la prédation là qui
est vraiment interrogée la prédation
dans le milieu naturel euh et là il y a
de la souffrance
indéiablement mais à partir du moment où
on est dans un cycle de la vie je pense
que on peut pas avoir
des estimer qu'une souffrance est
légitime et l'autre ne l'est pas enfin
bon si je
regarde on ne parle pas beaucoup de la
on a des chats en France qui sont à
l'origine de la disparition de 20
millions d'oiseaux par par an là aussi
il y a de la souffrance alors bien
entendu c'est pas un animal d'élevage
c'est pas un animal de rente mais
attention à ce que l'on met derrière la
souffrance parce que il y a pas de
petite souffrance et de grandes
souffrance voilà ce que je pouvais vous
dire merci Lucien
stion bien
oui merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs Monsieur le
Préfet moi je suis du départementveauuse
et il y a 3 mois la 5è meut de loup
a été identifié dans le Petit Luberon
pour ceux qui connaissent c'est dans un
périmètre compris entre Cavaillon
bonieux et lourd-marin zone touristique
par essence et les meuts sont situés
puisqu'il y en a cinq deux dans le
Ventou euh une sur le Grand Luberon une
sur le plateau d'Albion et une meut donc
dans le Petit Luberon aujourd'hui les
syndicats agricoles nous disent que le
nombre de loups progresse vous avez
identifié 1004 loups euh après
rectification hein puisque ah 104 oui
c'est ça j'ai mal vu 1104 euh en 2009 il
y avait 12 départements concernés par la
présence du loup euh 40 en 2019 et 44 en
2021 dans dans mon département 65
communes sont concernées sur 150 c'estàd
quasiment la moitié du du du
territoire et en 2023 nous avons
constaté 30 attaques dont 20 ont été
indemnisées
donc et alors pour compléter le tableau
les sociétés de chasse mais ça je crois
que c'est un peu partout se plaignent
également de la baisse de la présence du
gros gibier et je pense en particulier
au mouflon du manentou au cerf chevreil
et autres sanglier donc trois
questions trois questions le statut
européen du Loup vous en avez parlé un
petit peu tout à l'heure qui détermine
la condition de gestion du chefttel du
loup est-ce que vous pensez engager une
action efficace et j'ai déjà posé la
question au ministre qui ne répond pas
clairement là-dessus deuxième chose que
pourquoi pas ne créer des zones de
protection renforcé où le tir à lunett
thermique nocturne serait
autorisé et en même temps pour répondre
à la remarque que vous formulier avec
ces zones de de de de protection à
disposition des préfets de région
peut-être pour les adapter pour éviter
la sclérose de la du zone
hein c'est ce que vous évoquiez dernière
chose euh bon moi je suis regret de vous
dire les délais pour pouvoir tirer un
loup même dans tout le processus
d'autorisation comme vous le savez le
loup parcourt entre 10 et 15 km par jour
sur un territoire immense et que
attendre 48 he pour dire je donne
l'autorisation de tirer bah le loup je
suis désolé d'ailleurs vous l'avez
évoqué avec une louve que vous avez mis
plusieurs semaines à à trouver euh c'est
pas opérant je veux dire il faut que la
décision soit prise et que très vite
dans les 2 heures qui suivent on puisse
être autorisé à tirer voilà mes TR
questions merci Lucien et il neque
Jean-Marc Boyet le Massif Central oui
merci madame la Présidente je dirais
même le puit d'homme et la chaîne des
puits où il y
a un espace naturel qui est protégé
maintenant qui est classé UNESCO où il y
a un fort un fort pastoralismes c'est
votre collègue Michel Baudoin qui est
particulièrement à la pointe sur sujet
euh et donc on a des relations très
suivies entre le parc naturel régional
des Volcans les éleveurs les berger et
et donc l'ensemble de la protection de
l'espace je veux dire une protection de
la biodiversité qui est quand même très
importante et il se pose surtout le
problème de la conciliation des usages
et la conciliation des usages
aujourd'hui c'est entre le
pastoralisme c'est entre les activités
sportives rando parapante 44 et cetera
j'en passe é des meilleurs euh mais
aussi
euh les chasseurs et euh donc était mis
en place une brigade verte sur sur
l'ensemble du site il y a eu une brigade
de gendarmerie supplémentaire euh ma
question c'est euh aujourd'hui euh ne
vat-il pas falloir envisager des
créneaux d'utilisation d'espace dans le
temps de manière à ce que chacun trouve
sa place parce qu'on va vers de plus en
plus d'incidents malgré la présence de
la gendarmerie qui est relativement
importante c'est-à-dire je sujets qui
ont été abordés il y a quelques temps
qui était qui ont été très sensibles
c'estàdire la chasse le matin les
activités sportives l'après-midi je ne
sais pas en fait c'est c'est c'est mais
je pense qu'il faudra à un moment donné
peut-être trouver des solutions parce
que je pense qu'on va aller vers des des
problèmes relativement importants mon
deuxième point c'est la position de la
profession par rapport au loup il y a
quelques temps quelques années on était
sur une position syndicale qui disait il
y a pas de place pour les deux c'est le
loup ou c'est nous et j'ai j'étais une
réunion préfecture la semaine
dernière j'ai senti qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui une position
d'acceptation une position de de
cohabitation entre le loup et et et les
bergers où on est plus sur une position
d'éradication du LOU c'est plus le sujet
j'été quand même assez assez surpris de
cette position là donc je voudrais
savoir un peu quelle est votre position
là-dessus Monsieur le Maire madame la
Présidente et dernière question
subsidiaire est-ce que le statut des
loup du Loup vous en avez parlé Monsieur
le Préfet tout à l'heure est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est dans les
tuyaux est- c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est réfléchi actuellement parce que
le le le la directive de Berne qui dit
qui protège aujourd'hui le loup qui on
fait une espèce protégée est-ce que
c'est en discussion est-ce que ça n'est
pas parce que le fond enfin le le le
nœud du problème à mon avis il est là et
et et donc faudra peut-être qu'
évolution par rapport à ça merci euh
madame peut-être et puis ensuite pour
répondre à Monsieur
salmon euh pour répondre à Monsieur là
par rapport aux accords de libre échange
je pense que j'ai été très clairire sur
notre position par rapport à ça
évidemment c'est de l'incompréhension
effectivement la perte du chptel auovin
euh date date aussi de du règlement du
de l'histoire du Rainbow Warrior à
l'époque et depuis les années 85 on a vu
arriver contingents et évidemment on a
été la variable d'ajustement et
apparemment on continue de l'être avec
une vigilance aussi à avoir sur
l'Australie puisque maintenant c'est
l'Australie qui est qui qui fait part de
ses vité en terme de commerce de
commerce et et là aussi on risque d'être
la variable d'ajustement ce qui mettrait
la la filière à genoux complètement donc
voilà pour ça après le problème du
réchauffement climatique évidemment que
ça nous préoccupe et au plus haut point
puisque quand on est en prise directe
avec la pousse naturelle de l'herbe on
se rend bien compte que les sécheresses
successive impacte fortement le
potentiel alimentaire pour les troupeaux
donc là aussi pour recouper un peu avec
la prédation quand j'entends qu'il y a
des évolutions dans les mouvements de de
transumance des troupeaux des
redescentes d'estives plutôt ou que
c'est souhaitable par rapport
effectivement vous l'avez dit au fait
que les louves les louves apprennent les
petits à chasser vous comprenez bien que
on a plutôt tendance à monter plusut tôt
en estive et à redescendre plus tard
parce que quand on voit l'impact la
sécheresse sur les zones de plaines et
la transumance c'est essentiellement ça
hein on va en montagne l'été quand il
n'y a plus de ressources en plain euh
donc c'est c'est extrêmement
problématique et pas toujours réalisable
et en tout cas économiquement parlant
c'est c'est pas compatible quoi parce
qu'on se dit voilà si on perd le le
l'herbe enfin l'herbe les ressources
alimentaires que l'on trouve en montagne
ben on va pas pouvoir les remplacer en
pleine donc derrière ça suppose des
achats de fourage des coûts de
production qui augmentent et et tout ça
donc ça aussi c'est c'est problématique
mais le réchauffement climatique en tout
cas pour
l'élevage on n'a pas beaucoup de
solutions et et je dirais que autant on
a on essaie d'avoir des comment dire des
connaissances scientifique sur tout ce
qui est prairie temporaire pousse pousse
de l'herbe que que que l'on sème autant
on a très peu de retours sur le
comportement des espaces naturels et la
résilience de ces espacesl au changement
climatique et on se rend compte quand
même que bon moi pour pour ne parler que
d' cosses que je connais
particulièrement bien sur les cosses on
voit bien que l'impact de la de la
sécheresse et de les canicules que l'on
subit arrivve que font que les parcours
ne se régénèrent pas et ça c'estit c'est
un problème vraiment qui nous préoccupe
au plus haut point et et on a très peu
de retours scientifique et très peu
d'intérêt sur le sujet on essaie de
susciter mais bon c'est pas évident euh
vous avez abordé le problème de
laagrivoltaïsme évidemment que bon on
n'est pas contre les énergies
renouvelables pour nous l'agrivoltaïsme
c'est prioritairement évidemment sur les
bâtiments d'élevage sur tout ce qui est
artificialisé et pas sur les terres à
fort potentiel il n'empêche qu'on a été
amené à faire une charte parce que des
éleveurs qui sont propriétaires de leur
foncier comprennent pas de pas pouvoir
et on ne voulait pas que des que des des
projets à liby se montent en mettant des
ovins surous des panneaux donc ça c'est
pour nous c'est extrêmement important de
vérifier que de la production et
l'activité agricole reste
prioritaire dessous et en tout cas que
le revenu principal de
l'exploitation vient de de l'agriculture
et non pas des panneaux voilà après bon
il y a tout un problème juridique qui
n'est pas encore réglé hein parce que
autant c'est relativement simple quand
le propriétaire est utilisateur de
l'espace agricole autant quand il y a un
fermier avec un bail amphitéotique qui
se superpose sur un bail à ferme c'est
pas c'est pas on trouve pas la solution
par rapport à si vous voulez à la
sécurisation foncière de l'usage qui en
est fait voilà voilà donc on est
extrêmement vigilant par rapport à ça
voilà après j'ai relevé votre
attachement à l'élevage mais quand vous
êtes éleveur vous aimez vos bêtes euh
contrairement aux images et aux clichés
que l'on voit dans les médias qui qui
n'arrête pas de dire que vu que les
éleveurs
l'acte l'élevage des bêtes finit
toujours par un acte d'abattage c'est la
finalité pour avoir les produits ben
évidemment on mange pas une une
cottelette comme on arrache une carotte
bon ça il faut quand même le comprendre
donc à partir de là euh c'est je crois
qu'il faut pas il faut pas associer
l'acte d'abattage à la souffrance des
bêtes que l'on retrouve égorgé ou
éventré sur les territoires parce que
quand vous avez vos bêtes on a eu des
bêtes qui étaient gestantes et qui se
retrouvent avec l'agneau sorti on a des
bêtes qui sont pour un éleveur c'est
insoutenable et il faut pas assimiler ça
au même degré de sous souffrance telle
qu'on l'entend dans les abattoirs si on
a mis des abattoirs au normes c'est
justement pour éviter la souffrance de
l'animal contrairement à ce que l'on dit
donc voilà le cycle de vie c'est naturel
c'est sûr mais bon c'est pas pour autant
qu'on doit assimiler l'acte de prédation
à un acte d'abattage dans un un abattoir
agréé ça n'a rien à voir euh juste pour
répondre par rapport à euh à la
conciliation des usages c'est monsieur
qui a parlé de la conciliation des
usages c'est V que dans les les espaces
ou les parcs c'est encore plus prignant
je dirais la
problématique je voudrais faire part
quand même témoigner d'une difficulté
que l'on rencontre maintenant qui que
qu'on aborde pas souvent qui est un un
effet collatéral je dirais de la
prédation qui est que aujourd'hui on a
on a des remonté d'éleveurs qui se voi
refuser des renouvellements de
convention de pâturage parce que ils
vont sur des territoires avec des ovains
et qu'on a tendance à ne louer le
foncier à ne vouloir louer le foncier
qu'au beauovvin parce que ça génère
moins de prédation sur les territoires
et surtout la problématique des chiens
de protection donc pour nous c'est très
préoccupant parce que si le foncier se
ferme au à l'élevage au vin sous
prétexte qu'il y a des chien de
protection et qui a le multiusage à
concilier ça va ça posera problème voilà
on a eu également et quand je vous dis
que c'est pas uniquement au convention
pluriannuel j'ai eu moi-même à répondre
à une éleveuse qui allait signer un bail
à ferme proposé par le le proprié
qui était tout à fait d'accord à
condition qu'il a une clause dans son
bail qui disent qu'elle s'interdit de
mettre des chiens de
protection donc on en est là aujourd'hui
hein et ça il faut quand même comprendre
la difficulté dans laquelle se trouvent
les éleveurs par rapport à ça donc voilà
le conciliation des usages on sait très
bien ce que ça génère sur les
territoires je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de pédagogies à déployer pour arriver à
éduquer entre guillemets les les gens
qui vont sur les territoires qui savent
pas ce que c'est qu'un troupau le
comportement qu'il faut adopter
vis-à-vis des tropeaux et des chiens de
protection mais bon c'est encore un
souci un souci supplémentaire voilà et
la la position de la profession sur le
loup je peux pas dire que la profession
accepte le loup ça je ne peux pas
l'entendre parce que évidemment qu'il
n'y a pas d'acceptabilité en revanche on
le subit on le subit et on voit on voit
depuis des années qu'on subit à quel
point ben on est obligé de de se
protéger d'essayer de se protéger on est
obligé d'adhérer au aux différents plans
que qu'on nous qu'on nous impose parce
qu'on peut pas faire autrement voilà
tout simplement en revanche je parlerai
pas du tout d'acceptabilité mais je
n'irai pas non plus dans une éradication
nous le loup s'il n'attaque pas les
troupeaux ça nous pose pas de
difficultés majeur en revanche à partir
du moment où il attaque il faut lui
apprendre à ne pas s'approcher donc
évident évidemment que on met on met
toute ben oui ou alors ben c'est la mode
de nouveau c'est la mode on parle du on
parle du véganisme pourquoi on
napendrait pas au loup à être végan
pourquoi pas nous ça nous poserait aucun
souci hein je vous le dis ça nous pose
aucun souci voilà en revanche bon on
peut pas on peut on peut pas accepter ça
parce que à partir du moment où ça fait
des dégâts sur les tropaux c'est pas
acceptable c'est
tout qui souhaite prendre la suite non
Monsieur B allez-y
allez-y bon j'étais un peu choqué ce que
vous avez dit ben vous partez que vous
avez dit que on avait supporté des lou
jusquau Moyen-Âge je vous répondrai on a
supporté aussi la peste jusqu'au Moyen
Âge pour nous à notre niveau c'est la
même chose ou ou donc c'est pas un
argument deuxièmement en ce qui concerne
Nouvelle-Zélande il faudrait il faudrait
accrocher au prix des des agneaux des
moutons qui Nouvelle-Zélande le cout
carbone rendez compte que ça doit coûter
en carbone parce que parce que les
écologistes on devrait obliger ce que le
prix du mouton lorsquon aachète dans une
boucherie il y a le bilan carbone à côté
et ver la
différence les agau de chez nous c'est
zéro ce qui VI Nouvelle-Zélande alors
après puisque bon
éidement
s'agissant du partage de l'usage moi
j'appelle ça un conflit
d'usage un conflit il y a pas d'autre
solution un partage
temporel ce que je disais que le il pas
y avoir de loup quand il a la présence
du Troppau c'est quand il y a la
présence du troupau le troppeau Monte va
monter vers le 15 juin il va descendre
vers le je sais pas vers le début
octobre mais il faudrait monsieur
Monsieur le Préfet que une autorisation
de tir systématique il y a un loup qui
se pointe il dégage et puis il attend le
mois d'octobre pour venir faire ce qu'il
veut dans le pâturage et c'est pareil
pour les sportifs au moins au moins on
partage on laisse le loup faire ce qu'il
veut mais on lui fait comprendre parce
que tout le monde c'est vrai que le loup
certain
un animal très intelligent il comprendra
vite que il faut attendre le 15 octobre
pour pouvoir aller dans certain pâurage
et et ça ça peut être une piste sans
être absolutiste quand on
dit il y a pas d'autre solution que le
partage temporel alors après je faire
une remarque parce que bon je pense
qu'au Sénat la parole est
libre puisque vous êtes une commission
économique on a ma commune attendez y a
y a
une il y a des loups donc une m qui est
estimée alors il fantasme entre 10 et 30
LP qui vit dans un endroit qui est
autrefois au Moyen-Âge puisquil y des
questions au Sénat au Moyen-Âge occupé
par des
brigands le seul moyen qu'on a eu pour
se débarrasser des brigands c'est d'y
mettre le feu avec les conséquences
qu'il a eu au niveau géologique ça c'est
autre chose donc c'est pour vous dire
que le le lieu s'y prête pour les pour
les les
meut Monsieur le Préfet combien coûte le
loup VO le raisonnement qui est tenu par
certains de mes administrés qui ils ont
beau être des eururos ils ont quand même
une intelligence eu aussi pas que les
loups il raisonnent et il raisonnent ils
paient des impôts ils savent ce qui est
l'impôt si je me trompe vous me
corrigerez au niveau du chiffre mais je
sais que c'est une commission dans
laquelle les chiffres sont importants de
manière globale direct indirect le Pr du
loup depuis 20 ans coûte 30 millions
d'euros par an aux finances
publiques combien 34 34 je divise par
1000 54000 et j'arrive à combien par
loup 54000 € moi j'ai une une une
meutre maison d' loup prend le chiffres
qui coûte 540000 € par an alors ça coûte
540000 € par an d'argent public éit mê
pas on n pas capable de donner 50000 €
pour réparer une cabane pastorale c'est
là aussi qu' a il y a un problème
d'acceptabilité aussi et ça on le on le
dit pas trop
mais c'est c'est vraiment il va falloir
à un moment donné prendre des décision
quand même qui soit qui soit clair et ce
point financier on l'aborde jamais mais
mais les gens sont sont capables de de
le
comprendre alors maintenant sur le fait
que les éleveurs demandent plus
bon ça c'est je sais pas enfin moi j'ai
c'est pas le sentiment que j'ai surtout
avec les vaches je peux vous dire que
les les aurs de beauvin ils accepte pas
quand vous perdez une bourbille bon
alors tout dépend
écoutez nous chez nous il y a il y a des
propriétaires de très gros troupeaux on
appelle ça des herbesaciers il peut
avoir 3000 4000 brebis ça part dans les
alpag souvent ils sont du côté d'Ar en
en croc ça part dans les alpages et puis
de 3000 il en revient 2950 il 50 mots s
fout en face il y a
l'indemnité par contre vous avez un
éleveur qui a 300 brebis vous l'en
faites perdre à 50 vous vous le ruinez
donc il ils ont pas la même approche de
la problématique du
loup Mo dans tous les cas chez les beau
vins quce que vous perdez un beau vin
vous perdez pas 100 € hein et puis
surtout nous on a on a des éleveurs qui
ont des races qui ont des
qui Ahou il ple génétique des problèmes
c'est c'est nous on compare le loup à la
peste alors on dit à l'état vous avez
laissé venir le loup ok mais débarrassz
nous avons créé le problème je comprends
tous les efforts que vous faites écoutez
puisqu'on parlait du délai intervention
bon cet été il y a quand même 10 vaches
qui ont été tués aus de trois
attaques 12 jours pour pour autorition
de tir ça dit jamais le préfet dit je
fais ce que je peux 12 jours mais vous
rendez compte ce qu'on supporte nous les
élus les éleveurs qui disent ne tirez
pas on est dans le cadre légal attendez
l'autorisation vous n prenez pour imbées
alors et j'en ai terminé avec ça
excusez-moi je vous bêterai plus mais je
pense que c'est important jusqu'en 2000
jusqu'en 2000 le code des communes
prévoyait que le maire avait le pouvoir
sous le contrôle du préfet donc je vous
rassure
d'obvier les dangers produits par les
sangliers et les loups madame j'appelle
un chat un chat en juin 2000 a fait
supprimer
lou donc à l'époque il y avait une
jurisance du Conseil d'État qui était
bonne le meilleur échelon pour pour
régler ce point de Lou dont vous parliez
notamment dans les dans les plaines
c'est quand même le maire le maire il
est au courant de tout il compris ce qui
se passe
pas imaginez que j lou c'est lui qui
sera même de prendre les mesures et pour
le comptage vous sa comment on fait le
comptage ils font des des appels vous
savez des hurlements et puis ils
entendent alors en fonction de la
réponse comme les adultes répondent pas
ce sont les louvotau qui répondent si
avant de se faire gronder par les
adultes donc selon comin de
louvutoréponse on en
déduit il faut arrêter cette hisorie le
seul moyen qui est c'est quand même les
battu enfin chez nous moi autorisez-moi
à faire des batus je vous dirai com j'ai
de loup est-ce que c'est possible pour
un maire de pas savoir s'il entre 10 et
30 loups qui vivent à
proximité et je vis avec ça c'est je me
dis à tout moment parce que le loup est
quelqu'un de très imprévisible il va
passer devant un troupeau ça on l'a vu
pendant 3 ans il touchera pas et puis un
jour vous savez pas pourquoi c'est c'est
un massacre c'est il fait comme il
veut et donc
voilà merci euh on a parlé de beaucoup
de choses du réchauffement climatique
évidemment les forê en sont victimes
aussi et on connaît des dépérissements
donc des travaux sont faits pour mieux
cerner tous les déterminants de ce
changement climatique et pour essayer de
trouver des réponses en en sylviculture
ou en introduction de nouvelles espèces
je note ce que dit Madame singl sur le
non renouvellement des parcours il faut
intégrer ça dans les dans les travaux de
recherche sur la conciliation des usages
tout au long de ma carrière de Forestier
j'ai connu ça je ne pense pas qu'il faut
qu'il faille imaginer une gestion
nationale pour dire tel jour celui-là a
le droit d'aller là ou de ce ce genre de
chose en revanche j'en reviens à mon
projet de territoire je crois que c'est
là qu'il faut analyser les choses pour
voir comment on peut concilier
concrètement les souhaits des uns et des
autres dans leur projet
d'activité je comprends évidemment
beaucoup qu'on parle de la prédation
c'est un problème majeur qui se rajoute
à tous les autres que connaissent le le
pastoralisme mais comme le disait le
sénateur salmon tout à l'heure il faut
conserver cet élevage il faut conserver
ce pastoralisme alors regardons aussi
euh d'autres handicap qui sont
indépendants de la de la prédation et
c'est là que je voulais faire deux ou
trois propositions je l'ai fait en un
très court instant sur les associations
foncières pastorales qui sont quand même
un outil extrêmement performant pour
organiser l'activité d'élevage
extensif il y a une disposition
vis-à-vis des terrains boisés ou à boisé
qui dit que ils ne doivent être
qu'accessoires or dans dans des régions
comme la Corse ou dans des régions de de
basse montagne c c ces terres
forestières sont présentes et les
limités à un statut d'accessoire c'est
pénalisant je crois qu'il faudrait
revenir là-dessus de même que il y a
cette disposition qui dit qu'il faudrait
au maximum exclure les terrains relevant
du régime forestier non pourquoi euh là
laissons les élus dans leur capacité de
de décider à la composition de
l'association foncière pastorale qu'ils
souhaitent mettre en place mon deuxième
point c'est sur la chèvre on n' pas cité
cet animal depuis le début de cette
séance notre pauvre chèvre pourtant elle
nous fait des produits de grande qualité
et en forêt c'est le diable absolu elle
est interdite bah pourquoi je suggère
que l'on revienne sur le statut de la
chèvre et que comme pour le mouton le
cheval la vache et cetera et bien on
inscri le la présence de la chèvre dans
dans un plan local qui sera réfléchi et
qui lui permettra d'apporter ce qu'elle
peut
apporter deux autres choses encore
l'inscription de la destination
pastorale dans les PLU plui voilà une
chose qui pourrait aider à mettre en
place des équipements d'aide à
l'activité pastorale par parce que il ne
serait pas interdit par un classement
zone naturelle donc l'idée c'était
d'imaginer des zones à
à zones agricooles comme on fait les
zones agricoles les zones naturelles des
zones pastorales à réfléchir et puis
enfin l'idée d'une servitude
territoriale de passage de broutage et
d'équipement pastoral sur
certains parcours un propriétaire peut
peut complètement bloquer le passage euh
c'est quand même malheureux ça va
compromettre toute un un sentier de de
de de de transumance ou ou ou ou ou
l'exercice d'un parcours pastoral est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer une servitude qui
permettrait de lever cette interdiction
j'ai cité tout à l'heure l'idée des
subventions données à un collectif et
puis je termine quand même avec ce ce
qui me euh perturbe beaucoup c'est la
faiblesse des moyens de l'administration
au niveau départemental ou régional ça
pourrait quand même beaucoup aider
pardon d'avoir été trop long Monsieur le
Préfet je crois qu'on attend aussi
beaucoup sur le statut voilà strictement
protégé de l'espèce strictement protégé
oui merci madame la Présidente je vais
peut-être focaliser mon intervention
là-dessus puisque je vois que l'URE
tourne également où en sommes-nous sur
ce statut donc je vous ai dit que pour
la première fois le PNA évoque
l'éventuelle modification du statut et
nous demande de d'examiner les
conditions de possibilités les avantages
et les
inconvénients il y a d'ailleurs
parallèlement actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai été auditionné par la
députée Pascal
Boyer une
mission d'ailleurs au sein de la
commission des affaires économiques me
semble-t-il qui a pour objet
également d'étudier les conditions de
possibilité et les avantages et
inconvénients enfin la faisabilité
plutôt de la modification du
statut ceci dit euh donc les les choses
sont pour la première fois en cours
euh avec une volonté notamment du
ministre de l'Agriculture de porter le
débat au sein de la
Commission euh avec donc en s'appuyant
sur les études réalisées et puis sur ce
que va faire la mission d'information
euh ceci
dit on doit modifier deux textes on doit
modifier la convention de Bern et on
doit modifier la Directive
Habitat modifier une directive ce que ça
suppose comme vous le savez l'unanimité
des 27 membres et la convention de Bern
pour modifier la convention de Berne il
faut une majorité qualifiée au 2
tiers c'est dire tout le trajet alors ça
veut pas dire que c'est
impossible mais c'est dire tout le
trajet tout le parcours qui doit
être ouvert et et et
poursuivi enfin les choses sont pour la
première fois officiellement en
cours je pense que le le débat même sera
intéressant que ce débat soit porté au
sein de la
commission ce sera très
intéressant la présidente de la
commission sétant prononcé dernièrement
sur la modification du statut et sur le
danger de la démultiplication des loups
sur les territoires et parce que là ils
sont prés
attaqués mais ça a servi ça a servi ça a
servi à quelque chose
excusez-nous mais l'ambition du
gouvernement c'est bien ça d'aller
devant la commission la commission
devant ensuite
interpeller les les les chefs d'État sur
ce
sujet le fait j'insiste quand même sur
le le fait que pour la première fois ce
débat n'est pas
tabou pour la première fois on nous
demande
concrètement de présenter des
propositions de
modification la modification n'étant
peut-être pas le seul moyen ou la seule
voie pouvant être emprunté pour
modifier en grande partie
nos notre nos interventions sur sur le
loup parce qu'il y a aussi une voix
simple mais qui qui relève d'ailleurs du
seul de la seule souveraineté nationale
c'est le la fixation du taux de
prélèvement ce n'est que
national et là ça le le parcours est
quand même plus simple encore faut-il
convaincre là on en revient au
contentieux le l'ensemble des juges et
notamment le Conseil d'État qu'on peut
effectivement augmenter le taux de le
taux de prélèvement sans mettre à mal le
bon état de conservation de
l'espèce alors on va faire un tir groupé
si j'ose dire parce que l'heure tourne
et qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
questions donc je vous demande être
court et on va prendre des questions de
Toute à la file pierre medevieille
Vivian Artigalas Laurent Duplomb HRI
Cabanel Serge merilou Anne catriine
noisier alors pierre à toi merci madame
la Présidente merci Madame messieur pour
vos exposés essayer de faire
bref bon moi je pense je on a des choses
très intéressantes mais je pense qu'il
faut tirer la sonnette d'alarme on a
beaucoup parlé des des Alpes mais aussi
les les Pyrénées pardon
et j'ai moi j'avais réalisé une enquête
lors des dernières élections et nous
avons perdu sur les 30 dernières années
quasiment 50 % dans surface de pâturage
et d'estive donc je pense qu'il a
aujourd'hui urgence à agir on est face
un problème d'aménagement du territoire
carrément avec le développement don de
ta qui flambberont avec le réchauffement
climatique et ça va impacter des
activités bon comme le tourisme donc
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes alors
plan national je crois c'est c'est bien
on voit qu'on avance un petit peu un peu
doucement à mon goût mais moi je pense
qu'il faudrait un plan de coordination
notamment dans notre massif qui a qui a
le triste privilège je crois de de
cumuler tous les de prédation puisquen
plus du loup qui arrive d'Espagne qui
arrive des cantabri que nous avons aussi
l'ours avec quasiment 60 animaux
concentrés sur les même zone entre la
riège les Pyrénées au garonaises et les
autres Pyrénées plus le vautour les
vautours qui sont plus nourris en
Espagne qui s'attaquent à des nen jeter
plus euh c'est c'est un écurement je
crois total des responsables de filiè
Rovin enjoive de tous nos départements
bon clairement les plans sont
insuffisants souvent attaqués on a vu
les limites des mesures de protection
parce qu'il y a quand même des limites
bon on a parlé de l'intérêt des
cabanesureusement pour protection des
bergers même parfois et et heureusement
encore qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'intoxication au plomb anonyme qui sont
pas compté dans les plans parce qu'on
sait pas ce que ça serait sinon donc à
quant un plan bon vraiment réaliste qui
qui puisse résoudre ce problème je pense
qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça on ira
vers une disparition des pastoralisme
allez on reste dans les Pyrénées et pyé
aveci oui vous me permettrez d'insister
un petit peu on a pas encore beaucoup
parler des des Pyrénées des Hautes
Pyrénées moi je voulais juste quand même
rappeler que les Hautes Pyrénées c'est
le deuxème département pastoral de
France donc je crois que c'est important
d'en parler 1038 exploitations euh des h
Pyrénées 190 exploitants extérieur qui
viennent en transumance 261 unités
pastorales de 5 à 3500 hactares
comprises entre 500 m et 3 plus de 3000
m d'altitude euh 95 % des surfaces
rellèvent de la propriété communale et
j'ai été moi-même Monsieur le Maire
maire d'une commune de montagne
transumante 10000 hectar de terrain avec
beaucoup d'estiv un gardien embauché
mais avec une semaine pour faire toutes
les estive de la commune qui était
réparti sur des endroits jusqu'à
l'Espagne jusque voilà donc l'aide des
communes l'importance de l'aide aux
communes pas possibilité d'augmenter
plus de les
estives géré en régie et pas de
possibilité d'augmenter les moyens de de
la commune pour surveiller les estives
par manque par manque de moyens
l'économie pastorale c'est donc dans les
haut Pyrénées et dans les Pyrénées des
petites exploitations mais qui rendent
de nombreux services ça a été dit
l'entretien des paysages l'agrotourisme
la lutte contre l'embroussaillement et
contre du contre l'incendie la lutte
contre la fermeture des milieux moi je
voulais cette économie elle est très
diverse elle est très différenciée
d'autres d'autres d'autres d'autres
estives d'autres économie pastorale dans
France elle est très particulière elle
est aussi très fragile comme l'a dit
Pierre médeviel ce sont des estives
communales la plupart du temps qui
subissent la prédation de l'ours du loup
du vautour il l'a dit et je crois que on
cumule là pour nous ce sont aussi des
estives où les troupeaux sont en liberté
sur des grandes surfaces donc très
difficile à surveiller et c'est notre
patrimoine et c'est notre histoire
patrimoniale ce sont aussi une montagne
qui est très accessible donc on y
retrouve beaucoup de touristes qui ne
connaissent pas du tout ce qu'est le
pastoralisme avec des conflits d'usage
moi je voulais vous poser une première
question c'est comment mieux
territorialiser les mesures et les
dispositifs pour répondre aux besoins
particuliers de chaque territoire
pastoral et puis une deuxième question
au-delà des des MAEC qu'on qu'on dont on
s'en par comment mieux reconnaître les
services qui sont rendus au pastoralisme
par notre pour notre ce territoire vous
l'avez dit Madame le il faut se battre
tous les ans pour que les ICHN soient
reconnu comme intégrés dans la pâac pour
que la pque prenne en compte cette
montagne tous les enfin chaque fois
c'est une bataille une bataille comment
peut-on faire pour que ça soit mieux
reconnu C ces services rendus par le
passe merci Viviane Laurent Duplomb
oui madame la Présidente quand j'étais
Président de Chambre d'Agriculture il y
a quelques années et après avoir subi
des des attaques de ou sur mon
département je disais qu'au-delà du
problème économique qui deviendrait et
qui devient aujourd'hui une réalité sur
le fait de repousser les agriculteurs de
certains territoires je disais qu'il y
avait un problème psychologique et que
ce problème là les élevurs ne peuvent
pas accepter de le vivre ce problème
psychologique je le disais c'est comme
si le loup venez manger votre animal
domestique à l'intérieur de votre propre
cuisine ou dans votre propre maison
alors ça a attendu 10 à 15 ans avant
qu'on s'en rende compte officiellement
et il a fallu que le Ponet de Madame Van
derlyen se fasse totalement dévorer pour
qu'enfin la présidente de la Commission
européenne dise ces mots la
concentration de meut de loup dans
certaines régions d'Europe est devenue
un véritable danger pour le bétail et
virgule potentiellement virgule pour
l'homme
alors le maire de la commune leevernis
le disait tout à l'heure montesce que
disait les gens de mon pays ne sont pas
ne sont pas assez savants pour raisonner
de travers moi je me dis que quand mon
pays dépense 34 millions d'euros a
besoin d'un
préfet plus haut niveau de l'État de la
représentation de l'État pour traiter un
problème qui ne devrait pas être je me
dis franchement que je suis dans un pays
qui marche sur la tête alors on a vu les
agriculteurs retourner les panneaux mais
je pense que la réalité c'est celle-ci
plus on voit disparaître d'agriculteur
plus on voit des territoires se fermé
plus on a une augmentation d'attaque de
loup et moins on comprend que la réalité
du problème elle consiste en plusieurs
éléments qu'il faudra activer et activer
vite bien sûr qu'il faut augmenter le
nombre de prélèvements et arrêter de se
voiler la face dans une naïveté coupable
qui consiste à ne pas les compter parce
qu'on refuse de les regarder et vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le Maire on a plein
de méthodes pour PIR les compter quand
on veut les compter qu'en les écoutant
hurler par définition c'est qu'on veut
pas les compter et c'est ça la réalité
et quand on veut pas regarder les
problèmes des dégâts qui causent 34
millions d'euros de de coût pour l'État
et le contribuable c'est qu'on veut pas
les regarder donc à un moment donné un
il faut augmenter les prélèvements et de
façon drastique Monsieur le Préfet et ça
un ministre de l'Agriculture qui ne
comprend pas ça c'est un ministre de
l'Agriculture qui faut soit
l'agriculture française et l'élevage au
vin sur certains territoires le deuxème
élément c'est qu'il faut modifier la
convention de Berne nous ne pouvons plus
continuer avec une espèce qui devient
potentiellement dangereuse pour l'homme
de continuer de penser que cette espèce
doit être protégée et audelà doit être
surprotégé et si on veut même trouver
une autre solution on nous parle souvent
en France de surtransposition aux normes
européennes mais si le loup devient un
problème environnemental pour des
territoires entiers parce que ces
territoires seront fermés pourront avoir
des des des des risques d'incendie plus
élevé est-ce que la surtransposition
positive ne serait pas d'éliminer celui
qui empêche les moutons de pouvoir
garder ces territoires ouverts parce que
là les cûts pour nous seront encore plus
grands et pour les communes comme celles
de votre commune deviendront totalement
inhabitables donc pour tout cela moi je
le dis très clairement arrêtons de jouer
à ceux qui ne veulent pas regarder les
réalités en face arrêtons cette naïveté
coupable qui consiste à vouloir faire
des choses qui ne répondent pas à la
réalité du terrain et au moins une fois
au moins une fois prenons les choses en
main et arrêtons d'écouter tous ceux qui
nous racontent des fables et faisons
véritablement le travail pour ça bon
voilà Laurent alors Henry Cabanel
oui merci madame la Présidente d'abord
je voudrais remercier les intervenants
et et et vous m'en voudrez pas mais plus
particulièrement Brigitte Singla puisque
elle éit leveuse dans les rou dans ce
magnifique département de lerou et je
travaille souvent avec elle et oui il
est beau il est très beau
euh merci de nous avoir donné votre
point de vue sur l'activité économique
du
pastoralisme pour d'abord les éleveurs
mais ça a été évoqué par visiane mais je
voudrais revenir là-dessus sur
l'activité aussi touristique chez nous
dans dans dans leséros la fermeture donc
pour lutter contre la fermeture des
milieux et forcément lutter contre
l'incendie et permettre aussi aux
chasseurs de chasser davantage le
sanglier parce qu'il il occasionne
d'énormes dégâts dans
l'agriculture etéroltaise donc madame la
Présidente à vos propos liminires vous
avez évoquer les paiements pour services
environnementaux vous savez combien je
tiens sur cet outillà et je voudrais
savoir qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
de cet outil et est-ce que vous avez
donc des pistes de réflexion pour
éventuellement arriver à le mettre en
place 2è question euh au sujet donc du
statut des chas de protection vous avez
évoqué Monsieur le Préfet j'ai posé une
question au ministre lors de la mission
dans le PLF mais il ne m'a pas répondu
parce qu'il était en pleine réflexion
est-ce que vous avez des pistes de
réflexion puisque vous avez dit qu'il
faudrait légiférer la-dessus mais il
faut qu'à moment donné on ait une
proposition de loi là-dessus parce que
ça a été évoqué par certains de mes
collègues il y aura un conflit d'usage
aussi sur les territoires mais est-ce
que vous avez des pistes de réflexion
sur ce statut du Chen de prote
merci alors les deux derniers Serge mer
Catherine Loisier merci madame la
Présidente et merci à tous les
intervenants moi j'ai une réponse
pratiquement à toutes les questions donc
je vais pas les reposer cont du temps
mais je je profite de ma prise de parole
pour
témoigner de mon soutien à la filière au
vin à la filière élevage en général et à
la filière au vide puisque j'ai aussi du
pastoralisme chez nous mais sans loup
donc c'est quand même plus facile il est
comme il est proche du du cause du lot
il est
plutôt à vocation touristique hein donc
on n'en vit pas et heureusement parce
que je me demande comment vous faites
vous les éleveurs pour arriver à vivre
de votre métier et je pense que tant
qu'on n pas réglé ce problème là
c'est-à-dire la capacité pour des
éleveurs de vivre avec les fruits de
leur travail ça doit être un petit peu
désespérant et quand vient se rajouter
en plus les les contraintes liées à la
présence du loup ouou à d'autres
d'autres animaux voilà c'est c'est
simplement le témoignage de soutien à
cette filière auquelle je suis très
attaché parce qu'en plus vient se
rajouter la concurrence relativement
déloyale quand même quand on regarde à
pâqu dans les supermarchés les les les
les agneaux qui arrivent de pays non pas
exotique mais de pays lointains euh
voilà donc bravo et pour ce que vous
faites Anne-Catherine Loisier merci
madame la Présidente très très
rapidement parce que les les sujets ont
été évoqués juste rebondir effectivement
donc sur le le déploiement du loup et de
ces loups isolés en
plain et vous avez parlé du du de la
sonéloire du Morvent enfin toutes ces
zones finalement assez pauvres où
l'élevage est devenu l'unique activité
agricole et et donc la menace comme
comme comme chez vous en montagne quoi
la menace elle est lourde tu le disais
pierre en terme d'aménagement du
territoire que va-t-il rester dans dans
dans ces territoires et et je pense que
nos éleveurs ne sont pas forcément des
éleveurs de chiens et de Patau quoi donc
ça commence à devenir très compliqué
C et juste la la nécessité vraiment et
je voulais avoir votre avis là-dessus
sur la capacité qu'on va avoir à faire
évoluer cette approche donc de de de de
la maîtrise du du de la protection Enfin
du stat du loup parce qu'on le sait les
meutes elles produisent chaque année x
jeunes louftau qui vont aller chercher
ailleurs faire leur vie ailleurs donc de
toute façon même en gardant en fixant le
le nombre tel qu'il est actuellement on
va avoir sans cesse des loups qui vont
partir faire leur vie étendre les
territoires et les périmètres un loup il
a besoin d'un périmètre de chasse donc
rester dans la situation actuel c'est
nourrir des problèmes grandissants à
venir donc est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous pensez que cette prise de
conscience voilà au-delà du Ponet de
Madame vanon liner je ve dire auss qu'il
y a aussi des éleveurs de chevaux hein
et que ils peuvent aussi en pâtir il y a
de plus en plus de poulins qui sont
mataqués effectivement donc est-ce qu'il
y a cette prise de conscience que si on
reste sur les conditions le périmètre
actuel on va vers un problème
grandissant quoi on ne il ne peut pasêre
ça ne peut pas être figé on ne peut même
pas se contenter du je ve dire on garde
le nombre de loups actuel parce que les
les jeunes louftau iront faire leur vie
ailleurs je vous propose euh à nos
quatre invités à travers un mot enfin
une une conclusion de pouvoir peut-être
faire un packaging de l'ensemble de ces
dernières questions madame Singla à vous
oui bon d'abord sur le le côté des
services rendus par par l'élevage en
général et par le pastoralisme
particulièrement effectivement nous
avions jusqu'à maintenant l'habitude de
de faire ce qu'on appelle des mesures
agroenvironnementales hein avec ég
également des comment dire des des
documents de gestion pastoral qu'on
avait hein et que pour pour toujours
aller vers préservation de la
biodiversité prise en compte du milieu
force de constater que les budgets n'y
sont plus du tout hein et que toutes les
MAE il y a un cahier des charges il y a
des contraintes pour les éleveurs et que
le financement a fondu il est plus du
tout ce qu'il était donc vous comprenez
que même là ça va plus alors de là à
dire que il faut faire effectivement des
des PSE oui mais en dehors de la PAC
surtout en dehors de la PAC parce que
quand on voit et je voudrais revenir par
rapport au budget ça me permet de dire
que le budget qui est alloué aux mesures
de protection il est pris quand même sur
le budget agricole d'accord qui était
censé aller sur du développement
agricole et rural si on fait du
développement avec des mesures de
protection et et et la prédation nous on
comprend pas très bien he sur le terrain
voilà en revanche ça pèse lourd dans le
budget cet argent serait mieux utilisé
différemment euh tout ça aussi pour dire
que 20 % quand même et je tiens à le
souligner parce qu'on l'oublie souvent
reste à la charge des éleveurs il y a
une étude qui a été faite sur le lycée
de carmejeane euh qui montre les
surcouttes engendrés par la mise en
place notamment des moyens de protection
parce que c'est bien beau de dire on
regroupe les bêtes la nuit on fait un
parc de nuit mais qui va chercher les
bêtes dans des milieux comme ça ça prend
un temps voilà matin et soir c'est quand
même un temps important les chiens de
protection il faut les il faut les
nourrir il faut les entretenir euh qui
s'en occupe si ce n'est l'éleveurs donc
tout ça quand le salarié le berger
salarié euh s'en va en congé qui le
remplace euh tout ça ça reste quand même
important et et à la charge des éleveurs
se rajoute à ça alors pas pour les
communes qui ont leur propres leurs
propres salariés bergers salarié
peut-être mais vous savez que maintenant
la conditionnalité sociale fait partie
des de la conditionnalité globale des
des des aides de la PAC et que là aussi
la responsabilité est accrue sur
leséleveurs donc tout ça se rajoute donc
oui les services que que l'on rend
effectivement ils sont pas assez pris en
compte donc aujourd'hui essayer de voir
comment on peut construire des
prestations de servicees environnemental
ça serait quand même un juste retour des
choses je dirais surtout quand on voit
et et là bon c'est c'est pas de
l'entretien du territoire mais moi qui
suis attaché au cost CV qui ont été
classé au patrimoine culturel matériel
de de l'humanité on se rend compte que
sur le plan touristique tout le la
richesse du bâti vernaculaire qui a été
qui a été fait par justement nos nos
ancêtres nos bergers hein et c'est c'est
une formidable reconnaissance pour eux
il était temps je dirais parce que ça a
été quand même l'objet d'un dur labeur
pour construire tout ça mais quand on
voit les drailles tout ce que ça génère
en terme de d'architecture sur les
territoires et de richesses tout ça
aussi ça a jamais été Pr pris en compte
donc on a toujours apporté des
externalités positives qu'on arrive pas
à monayer à faire prendre en compte en
revanche moi mon point de vigilance il
est que le PS doit venir en plus et que
ça ne doit pas servir
de d'excuse pour dire vous êtes payé par
un PSE on vous diminue les aides de la
PAC et on vous enlève l'éligibilité des
surfaces et ça il faut toujours garder
cet équilibre pour dire attention on est
dans le collimateur on le sait hein
voilà all aller rendre l'gip des espaces
naturels c'est pas c'est pas forcément
dans l'air du temps maintenant derrière
on met des notions de productivité des
choses qui nous échappe un peu aussi
parce que la spécificité justement de
ces traditions pastorales fait que bon
voilà on peut pas rivaliser avec de avec
d'autres systèmes en revanche faisons
attention moi je suis très favorable
mais il faudra monter quelque chose qui
ne viennent pas porter l'excuse pour
nous jeter de des politiques publiques
en général voilà
merci Monsieur le Maire bon pour être
bref bon je pense vous avez tous
conscience vous êtes sénateur de
l'importance que jou les les communes
pastorales dans la défense du
pastoralisme on est en première ligne on
est au front euh si cela est possible je
vous invite à réfléchir à une DGF
pastorale donc spécifique au commune
pastorale comme il y a eu desgf
touristiques le critère c'était commune
touristique d'avoir un certain nombre de
lits de lit banalisés et vous étiez
automatiquement éligible c'est un plus
et on pourrait peut-être faire pareil
pour le pour le
pastoralisme parce que ça permettrait
ensuite de laisser quand même aux élus
le pouvoir ensuite de territoire par
territoire commune par
commune d'employer des moyens pour
défendre le pastoralisme voilà c'est ce
que je conclurai au nom des communes
past
merci beaucoup monsieur DX vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose et on terminera
avec le préfet CD juste un mot j'adhère
totalement à à ce que a dit Madame singl
sur les les
PSE le l'éleveur doit vivre d'abord de
son travail et des produits qu'il
façonne et et et met en vente ensuite il
y a toute cette dimension des aides qui
est essentiel sur les aides européennes
euh je suggère l'idée d'une MAEC silvo
pastorale parce qu'on est de
l'agriculture on est de la forêt mais
cette conjonction que constitue le
syvoastoralisme
elle n'est pas reconnue or une MAEC
silvoastoral pourrait être un moyen
d'éviter toutes les chikaya dont vous
parliez sur la proratisation des
surfaces et cetera qui sont quand même
un handicap et une complexité et sur les
PSE oui il faut progresser dans ce sens
alors le mot de la fin Monsieur le
Préfet
CD merci madame la
Présidente de réponses très brèves sur
la territorialisation madame la
sénatrice oui on peut territorialiser le
PNA le prévoit donc on peut adapter nos
moyens de protection au territoire si ce
n'est
que il faut pouvoir l'étudier ceci or
pour la première fois nous avons obtenu
à l' du PNA 1 million par an pour
financer des expérimentations ou des
mesures nouvelles et ça ça permettra de
répondre à cette demande de
territorialisation me semble-t-il sur le
projet de de statut du chien de
protection nous avions élaboré un projet
de statut du chien de protection euh je
pense que le le ministre a été prudent
parce que ce projet n'a pas rencontré
comment dire
un grand enthousiasme dans les les
directions ministérielles donc ceci ceci
dit maintenant c'est dans le PNA donc il
faut avancer le projet est sur la table
on peut le modifier et cetera mais enfin
il y a un projet qui qui est sur la
table sur votre question madame la
sinatrice et ça sera aussi Monot mon mot
de
conclusion je pense que le ce PNA pose
pour la première fois la question de la
maîtrise de la
population et nous demande d'évoquer
cette question tant un un échelon
hexagonal qu' un échelon
européen en se demandant il y a des
seuils de viabilité démographique mais
il y a aussi un seuil de viabilité
génétique il y a le bon état de
conservation qui suppose une extension
dans l'ensemble des habitats naturels de
l'espèce voilà où est-ce qu'on en
est on va avoir en
2025 une rencontre avec la la commission
pour savoir où est-ce qu'on en est du
bon état de conservation de l'espèce je
crois qu'à ce moment-là les questions se
poseront de manière
concrète est-ce que voilà où est-ce
qu'on en est où est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut continuer supposeer que cela
continue à avoir une augmentation
exponentielle de
l'espèce malgré les 19 % de
prélèvement ce qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire pour une population
sauvage vous vous considérez qu'il y a
19 % de prélèvement 15 % de 15 % de
mortalité naturelle ouou accidentelle
donc il y a un taux de survie de 66
% mais 66 % normalement pour une
population sauvage c'est la c'est
l'atteinte limite or là on a on a une
augmentation de près de 12 % par
an faudrait faudrait faudrait
comprendre donc je vous
répondrai oui pour la première
fois on a a upation de
savoir comment on pe enfin est-ce
jusqu'où on va on aurait pu mais on na
pas fait pour des raisons parce que ça
pas été quand même simple entre entre
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
mais on aurait pu se dire bah voilà
voilà la limite on se pose la
limite on l'a pas fait si ce n'est que
le PNA prévoit d'une certain d'une
manière détournée qu'on le fasse et
rapidement c'est-à-dire avant
2025 bien écoutez sur ces paroles on va
en rester là on va vraiment vous
remercier très sincèrement madame et
Messieurs d'avoir consacré pratiquement
3h à notre réunion de commission vous
avez vu que voilà il y a aussi des gens
qui sont à la fois passionnés attachés à
leur territoire attachés à l'élevage et
au pastoralisme donc merci beaucoup je
souhaite à l'ensemble de nos collègues
mais également à nos invités de très
belles fêtes de Noël de très belles
fêtes de fin d'année vous dire que voilà
on aura beaucoup de pain